continue des liens passés entre monsieur
Chaf Hauser je dois le dire correctement
je pense et ça failli politique le
président de notre commission d'enquête
Jean-Philippe a souhaité se déporté nous
revient donc l'honneur de préciser cette
série cette réunion je cherche un user
je vous remercie d'avoir répondu notre
convocation comme vous le savez notre
commission de travail depuis plusieurs
mois déjà sur les ingérences de
puissance étrangères dans la vie
politique économique et auprès des
relais d'opinion de notre pays nous
souhaitons donc à ce titre cueillir
votre témoignage concernant les
relations que vous entretenez de longue
date avec la Russie
mais bien sûr non pas pour vous le
reprocher mais pour établir si vous avez
pu être le vecteur d'opération
d'ingérence de la part de ce pays dans
la vie politique nationale française
nous interrogerons en particulier sur
votre rôle dans l'obtention par le Front
national à l'époque de deux près auprès
de banques russes en 2014 et 2017 et la
rémunération que vous auriez perçue en
échange
à la suite d'une première vérification
de vos déclaration d'intérêt en décembre
2014 par le Parlement européen nous
n'auront pas que le parquet national
financier a ouvert une enquête relative
à ces sujets c'est d'ailleurs la raison
pour laquelle le président Jean-Philippe
Tanguy a accepté après avoir consulté le
membre du bureau que votre avocat soit
présent à vos côtés
il n'appartient pas notre commission
d'enquête bien entendu de se prononcer
sur la qualification pénale des faits ou
sur la commission de fait constituant un
délit nous tiendrons en tiendrons
strictement à ce qui est l'objet de nos
travaux à savoir les ingérences et les
menaces d'ingérence de puissance
étrangères
cette audition je le précise est
retransmise en direction le site de
l'Assemblée nationale il enregistrement
vidéo sera ensuite disponible à la
demande je vous laisserai la parole pour
les interventions liminaire d'une
dizaine de minutes puis nous
poursuivrons nos échanges sur la forme
de question et de réponses auparavant je
vous rappelle que l'article 6 de
l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires imposent aux
personnes auditionnées par une
commission d'enquête de prêter le
serment de dire la vérité toute la
vérité rien que la vérité je vous invite
donc à lever la main droite et à dire je
le jure
je vous remercie vous avez la parole
pensée appuyez sur le micro comme vous
la prendrez
oui je chers collègues je vais
présenter
le contexte
de
mes engagements au niveau international
pour que vous puissiez bien comprendre
justement pourquoi il n'y a pas eu
d'ingérence extérieure
donc je vais vous relater pendant 10-15
minutes le contexte pour faciliter vos
questions par la suite
en 1988 je suis chef de la coopération
internationale
de la région Alsace le président de
cette région Marcel rue deloff et
également fondateur de l'Assemblée des
Régions d'Europe et donc je m'occupe
également de la coopération
des régions d'Europe du particulièrement
pour
l'Est ouest et le Nord Sud
je suis d'origine professeur de
philosophie j'ai un ami qui est
rocco-boutiglione qui s'avère être aussi
le conseiller du Saint-Pierre pour
Jean-Paul II pour les pays de l'Est
et il me propose
de sous couvert de l'Assemblée des
Régions d'Europe de me rendre dans les
pays de l'Est pour faire le lien avec
l'opposition dans ces pays
c'est ce que je fais donc le 8 septembre
89 un an après je réunis l'ensemble de
ces opposants à Strasbourg et à ce
moment-là la région Alsace me donne un
million de francs enfin de nos forums
démocratiques qui vient d'être
constitués européens avec ces leaders
des pays de l'Est et la ville de
Strasbourg et le département 500 000
le président hongrois vient pour la
première fois pour soutenir Arpa gun
cette initiative en France
et se crée également l'agence de
coopération décentralisée internationale
dont je suis le délégué général
pour gérer la coopération des régions de
l'Europe
je crée également l'Académie européenne
avec les directeurs des anciennes
fondations
le directeur de la Fondation Adenauer le
directeur de la Fondation gars Spirit et
puis le directeur une directrice en
l'occurrence de la Fondation Schuman
je le fais en les violences d'une
certaine manière parce que
d'emblée ma perspective je reviendrai
sera également
l'élargissement à la Russie et puis avec
une approche qui n'est pas atlantiste
et pour cela je m'appuie sur un sur un
ami que je connais depuis longtemps je
suis aussi au cabinet de Chaban entre 86
et 88 c'est ils vont Bourges nous
relançons pas Europe France avec cette
idée d'une Europe d'Atlantique à l'oral
dès cette époque dont pas d'Europe
France nous repensons de pouvoir
européen avec un
la suppression de la Commission
et puis un secrétariat du Conseil
implanté à Strasbourg et puis un
parlement qui reste aussi l'émanation
des états
pas d'un peuple européen
depuis cette période tout en étant
fonctionnaire territorial depuis 82 je
suis également consultant car la loi en
Alsace le permet
le permettait à l'époque
et donc à ce titre là je mène
différentes activités d'abord comme
attaché parlementaire en plus de ma
fonction
de Pierre chilet Marcel rue de loffe des
sénateurs et ensuite parce que je serai
également le représentant des lits c'est
pour ça que je connais bien la Chine
puisque Ellie Levin était l'homme de
Saül Heisenberg qui a introduit les
entreprises israéliennes en Chine
pourquoi vous raconter
ce message
tout pouvoir cherche d'une certaine
manière de l'influence sous des formes
diverses
à la région Alsace ou à l'Assemblée des
Régions d'Europe au département à la
ville de Strasbourg nous cherchons cette
influence pour Strasbourg d'une manière
positive
et d'une certaine manière nous
intervenons dans la politique étrangère
de ces pays
d'abord avant soutenant les liens contre
le communisme
l'anticommunisme et et pour une certaine
conception des droits de l'homme et de
la démocratie
tout État travaille d'une certaine
manière pour ses intérêts propres ainsi
trouvions-nous à l'époque tout à fait
normale d'intervenir dans la politique
intérieure d'autres États pour une juste
cause
sur nous apprécier la réciproque sans
doute que non mais ça c'est toujours la
politique des deux poids de mesure
par ailleurs quand je vais avec en Chine
avec Élie Levine dans les années 90 nous
utilisons d'autres influence auprès des
politiques chinois pour ouvrir la Chine
aux entreprises israéliennes et quand
j'imploque Logan en Hongrie
je me sers d'une information à la table
et
à côté où j'apprends que les gens les
représentants les directeurs de
l'entreprise nationale hongroise veulent
quitter cette entreprise pour en faire
profiter
Logan français l'entreprise nationale
donc
ce bilan
existe toujours
quand vous travaillez pour le camp du
Bien c'est à dire l'Occident libéral
sous influence américaine qui prétend
être la communauté internationale
définissant le bien et le mal
vous êtes un grand patriote mais si vous
voulez vous extraire de ce camp
poursuivre par exemple une politique
indépendante de ces intérêts car les
intérêts américains ne sont pas toujours
nos intérêts
ceux de la France et du peuple de France
et que vous associez la France vous
coopérer vous créez un une alliance avec
des puissances comme puissance
d'équilibre avec la Russie et la Chine
par exemple comme De Gaulle l'a fait
alors vous êtes considérés comme
dangereux et on ne vous apprécie plus
on pense c'est une histoire Branca qui a
fait un bon livre à vous éliminer
physiquement bien que vous soyez chef
d’état de la France avec 80% des
Français qui vous soutiennent
on fait tout pour vous affaiblir on
soutient la rébellion en Algérie avec
des coups de dollars on soutient la
rébellion dans nos colonies à coup de
dollars on a un film l'extrême droite et
l'extrême gauche à coup de dollars le
centre les parties de droite
des syndicats
on achète la presse et on achète des
journalistes à coup de dollars
c'est des histoires des relations
historiques
si on en croit nos historiens de la
France avec les Américains avec les
États-Unis
et ils ont cherché dès le début
à nous ôter notre indépendance avec le
billet de drapeau rappelez-vous
bien français fabriqué aux États-Unis
ils ont voulu remplacer Giro je suis
désolé mais je voudrais vous je voudrais
vous ramener sur le sujet s'il vous
plaît je pense qu'on dérive un petit peu
et peut-on en revenir au sujet qui nous
préoccupe s'il vous plaît je vais y
venir rapidement s'il vous plaît
non je me moque pas de vous je vous
raconte une histoire qui est celle de
l'influence des États-Unis dans ce pays
c'est le président qui donne la parole
ici donc je vous demanderai de revenir
sur le sujet s'il vous plaît et pas de
faire des échanges personnels merci au
revoir
je vais venir dans les années 90
et la Russie qui vous intéresse merci
dans les années 90
je vois comment
ayant rassemblé l'opposition dans ces
pays de l'Est étant plus
particulièrement
quelqu'un qui est observateur à ce
moment-là
de ce qui se passe dans ces pays je vois
comment les États-Unis construisent
d'une certaine influence
et non seulement comment il construit
cette influence
mais comment ils ont mis
particulièrement
en Pologne
un système qui leur permettait de faire
que la défense de la Pologne se fasse
par des conseillers américains passons
là-dessus mais surtout que il n'y ait
pas d'appel d'offres pour ce qui
concerne le choix des avions
il s'avère que le président du parti de
cette époque
était également un ami et qu'il avait la
majorité au Parlement et j'arrive à
faire que
il y ait un appel d'offre autrement dit
que le président la diète
demande
au ministre de la Défense sous couvert
d'enquête comment se fait-il que il y a
eu un leasing pour les F-16 alors même
que il n'y a pas eu d'appel d'offres ce
qui bloque le leasing
et
suite à ça je suis amené à travailler
pour
Thalès stegma et Dassault pour suivre
l'offre
donc de Dassault contre les effets je
tiens à vous signaler ça parce que
dès cette époque
je me suis rendu compte que
la main mise
étrangère ici en l'occurrence sur la
Pologne était extrêmement présente nous
faisons la meilleure offre à l'époque
j'ai enfin
demandé plusieurs fois que le Président
de la République Vienne
alors que le président des États-Unis
s'est blessé deux fois cela n'a pas été
possible
et j'ai demandé il s'avère que François
loz que je connais bien puisque je lui
ai succédé un peu avant 1980 comme chef
du Service régional de l'énergie
qui est ministre du Commerce extérieur
souhaite venir également me soutenir
il n'obtient pas ce soutien
toujours est-il que nous faisons la
meilleure offre et que malgré tout
je ne sens pas le soutien des autorités
françaises
pour quelles raisons je n'en sais rien
mais je dois vous avouer que cela m'a
profondément troublé je dois également
vous dire que si notre offre était loyal
celle de la partie américaine ne l'était
pas monsieur
revenez sur la Russie s'il vous plaît
merci pourquoi vous expliquer tout ceci
je vous explique tout ceci parce que
vous devez comprendre que j'ai un
engagement très tôt
dans les affaires internationales
et que cet engagement dans les affaires
internationales se poursuit dans
différents pays
je le fais à la demande
à l'époque du Saint-Père et
roccobuciglione pour faire le lien de
l'opposition dans les pays de l'Est je
vais en Russie
également à cette demande dès la chute
du mur
je ne vois pas d'opportunités immédiate
et donc c'est pour cela que je
n'y vais que en 1992 j'accompagne Marcel
rüloff membre du Conseil constitutionnel
et en 1995 où nous signons un accord
entre la Région Alsace et la région de
Moscou
je cherche en vain un partenaire sur
lequel appuyer l'Europe indépendante
jusqu'à l'oral
et je ne trouve à vrai dire sous à ce
moment en Russie que des partenaires qui
sont sous influence américaine
et donc ce n'est que
je n'irai en Russie que plus tard en 98
99 que l'Académie européenne que je
préside signe un accord avec l'Académie
de sécurité nationale russe accorde
coopération pour voir comment nous
pouvons renforcer les liens économiques
spirituel politique pour faire
de l'Europe continentale une puissance
d'équilibre par rapport au monde que la
Chine l'Asie et puis par rapport aux
États-Unis tout ceci dans la perspective
aussi de l'indépendance
de la France
par la suite
je m'iran pour une mission officielle
également en 2004 car l'Académie
européenne a travaillé pour total sur
les perspectives de ce que signifie
l'approvisionnement
de la Russie si elle faisait face au
contrat et aux besoins
en gaz de l'Asie et de l'Europe cette
étude que nous menons avec un certain
nombre d'universitaires dont Jacques
Sapir
montre très clairement que nous aurons
des problèmes d'approvisionnement et
qu'il faut transmettre un savoir-faire
au niveau technologique pour sécuriser
nos approvisionnements car si nous
devions chercher le gaz ou le pétrole
nous sommes donc en 2004
si nous devions chercher le gaz ou le
pétrole du côté américain il nous
faudrait
une dizaine d'années pour construire
tous les bateaux nécessaires et cela
entraînerait des coûts si important que
nous ne serions plus compétitifs nous
faisons un séminaire avec le ministre
des gens donc tout ceci c'est une
mission officielle je mène ces
opérations en présence d'un membre du
cabinet permanent du ministre de
l'économie
nous faisons donc un forum présidé à la
fois par le ministre des vins qui seront
à l'occasion à Moscou et sur la
coopération entre la France et la Russie
en matière d'efficacité énergétique je
suis désolé de vous couper largement du
temps qui vous était imparti parce qu'on
est déjà 17 minutes et ce que je ne
voudrions c'est que nous arrivions
directement au sujet pour lequel nous
avons convié qu'il s'agit du pré
et donc il faudrait se rapprocher un peu
plus de la date de 2014 s'il vous plaît
oui mais vous ne pouvez pas comprendre
le pré russe si vous ne l'insérez pas
dans cet environnement nous nous
comprenons mais non pas non plus avoir à
faire à un historique total de plusieurs
heures donc là nous sommes à 17 minutes
je vous propose d'avancer un petit peu
je continue à travailler d'ailleurs à la
demande également avec un conseiller du
un ancien conseiller Europe de l'Elysée
nous faisons ainsi un séminaire je le
dis parce que nous sommes en 2006 au
Parlement européen sur la défense
européenne avec la Russie
tout ceci doit être rappelé le pré russe
bon
le pré russe puisque vous êtes et vous
m'empêcher président de pouvoir
je vous demanderai de respecter la
présidence ensuite nous avons des règles
de fonctionnement nous avons donné une
dizaine de minutes sont bientôt à 20
minutes à 17
minutes cela faisait si je suis désolé
j'ai la convocation de toute façon nous
avons débordé nous ne pouvons pas
continuer sur 2004 et passer encore 10
minutes avant d'arriver à 2014 donc je
vous demande de revenir sur le sujet le
sujet étant le pré russe à partir de
2014 s'il vous plaît
pourquoi y a-t-il le pré russe
parce que
Marine Le Pen et Front national trouve
aucun source de financement aucune
banque aucune banque vous m'entendez
bien
du système occidental
ne veut lui prêter elle rencontre ses
difficultés dans un premier temps je
pense à une banque d'État que je connais
parce qu'elle est son vice-président son
premier vice-président est un ami
Abu Dhabi
nous préparons le contrat tout est fait
pour signer
et le jour où nous devons signer
la personne est malade il faut qu'elle
parte rapidement dans le malade ça maman
est malade il faut qu'elle parte et
on peut pas signer et on ne signera
jamais par pression extérieure
je dis alors à Marine Le Pen que
dans le cadre de la sphère
occidentale le système est bouclé
et que donc
nous pouvons trouver faut sortir de
l'orbite occidental compte sous contrôle
absolu américain nous ne pouvons donc
trouver que du côté chinois du côté de
l'Iran
la Chine que je connais bien puisque
j'ai été également en 2008 j'ai
représenté d'assaut Falcon avec
l'exclusivité mais aussi pour parler
d'autres questions plus stratégiques
chinois Iran ou la Russie
Marine Le Pen considère moi aussi
d'ailleurs personnellement que
la Russie est sans doute ce qui a de
mieux parce que c'est quand même
l'Europe et puis reste cette tradition
aussi de lien avec la Russie
nous sommes en 2013
les événements de Maïda n'ont pas encore
eu lieu
et donc nous nous
décidons prendre
la Russie
nous entendons nous rencontrer plusieurs
banques et nous choisissons une banque
Rousseau Russo tchèque parce que c'est
une banque qui est aussi une licence
européenne
le motif d'avoir choisi cette banque
c'est parce qu'elle a aussi une licence
européenne
et et donc
la question n'est pas la question du
prairus la question est comment se
fait-il que au niveau du monde
occidental
le rassemblement national ne trouve pas
une seule banque qui lui prête c'est ça
la question fondamentale
ça aurait pu être un prêt chinois serait
peut-être un prêt iranien iranien ça
aurait été un peu plus compliqué mais le
prêt chinois ça aurait pu être fait
ou un prêt mirati je pensais aux Émirats
mais impossible
bon
et non seulement après les choses se
poursuivent non seulement après avoir
fragilisé le rassemblement national on
essaye de fragiliser la présidence
elle-même
Marine Le Pen car lors des
présidentielles de 2017
Marine Le Pen c'est
porter caution personnelle
[Musique]
et nous obtenons un prêt
d'une banque philippine là aussi
nous nous déplaçons cette fois-ci on
nous prévient même pas de la sincérité
de vouloir signer et de faire ce prêt et
l'Administrateur extérieur au dernier
moment
sous pression extérieure puisque c'est
un administrateur extérieur
refuse et met son veto
et donc
nous n'avons pas pu avoir ce prêt aux
Philippines il doit rester donc plus que
la possibilité soit de retourner dans
l'orbite de ce qui n'est pas occidental
soit de
[Musique]
trouver une personne physique qui arrive
à à faire un prêt au parti qui lui-même
bon et
après
avoir cherché dans l'urgence
puisqu'il y avait la nécessité de payer
des entreprises
nous sommes après les élections
présidentielles c'est bien clair
et bien nous avons trouvé une personne
qui pouvait faire un prêt avec des amis
des amis émiratis d'ailleurs
et et donc c'est dans ce contexte là que
j'interviens à nouveau ce qui n'est pas
connu moins connu parce qu'il faut aussi
savoir que l'espoir du prairus sort
comme quoi j'aurais touché une
rémunération
des
des Russes
or le contexte n'est pas du tout
celui-ci pour ce prêt
le contexte était que
[Musique]
le Rassemblement National Marine me
disait tu peux faire ça gratuitement et
que
moi-même je ne pouvais pas le faire
gratuitement parce que ça la entraîne
des frais importants les frais d'avocat
des frais de montures de dossier etc
et en accord avec elle
avec une
la signature de la présidente et un
accord du rassemblement national il a
été d'accord que je facturais la banque
pour le travail qui a été fait et on
s'est entendu pour un montant qui était
de 140 000
et qui correspond je vous cache pas que
si j'avais facturé en tant
qu'indépendance que j'étais le montant
était nettement supérieur
puisque plus de la moitié de cette somme
c'est des frais de voyage et des frais
d'avocat
et que c'est une affaire qui a duré un
an
et qui a demandé des réseaux
internationaux
donc
c'est dans ce contexte là que l'affaire
sort aux États-Unis d'abord
ou un député aurait eu
de l'argent
d'ailleurs pas
patron pour cette raison là le contexte
ne poserait peut-être la question
pourquoi ça sort aux États-Unis
et bien et que j'ai un
journal d'investigation connu qui dit
qui m'appelle pour me dire nous avons la
copie de du Swift
montrant que vous avez touché 140000
euros en l'occurrence il s'agira d'une
société au Luxembourg et pas d'une
société russe même si cette société est
contrôlée en partie mais c'était une
société au Luxembourg
par des Russes et donc
sur ce sur cette affaire qui d'ailleurs
est
vous me posez une question qui concerne
directement l'enquête vous n'auriez pas
à me la poser
sur cette affaire je n'ai rien à me
reprocher
ma connaissance de la Russie est
reconnue
je tombe pas du ciel
je suis président de l'Académie
européenne qui a traité des plus grands
contrats pour Total d'assaut Snecma
enfin pour toutes les grandes sociétés
françaises
il n'y a jamais eu d'affaires me
concernant tout s'est toujours fait
proprement
et donc
nous en sommes là
la seule chose c'est qu'on parle du
prairus mais on ne parle pas des raisons
qui font qu'aucun Bank en Occident ne
veuille prêter à cette époque là du
moins au rassemblement national parce
que la question elle est là
elle ne parle elle n'est pas du prairus
qu'on a qu'on a été obligé de trouver
une solution hors de l'Occident
c'est ça la question fondamentale et la
question d'avoir monté toute cette
affaire par médias interposés avec des
dossiers donnés tout fait
par cette officine d'investigation comme
elle l'avait fait avec le rainbowa
Warrior déjà à l'époque cette même
officine pour Hernu pour déstabiliser la
France
ceux-ci ce sont des histoires qu'on peut
constater est connu donc moi je constate
simplement une chose c'est qu'on est
allé monter une affaire pour faire
diversion sur le fond de l'affaire qui
est comment se fait-il qu'aucune banque
occidentale ne prête à un parti
et ça c'est la question de front
et comment se fait-il qu'après avoir
fragilisé le rassemblement national on
fragilise on essaie de fragiliser
également sa présidente ça c'est la
question de fond
et la question de fond si on voulait
être démocrate serait les frais que cela
induit
parce que cela induit des frais
évidemment pour le rassemblement
national et qui font qu'aujourd'hui
on a souvent parlé des dettes du Front
National
et du rassemblement national le
rassemblement national pour trouver les
moyens à dû engager un certain nombre de
frais qui seraient tout à fait normal
que la République si on voulait jouer en
démocratie l'équilibre
rembourse remboursa donc ça c'est la
question c'est la question de fond voilà
si vous avez d'autres questions
personnelles
puisque vous avez utilisé largement le
temps qui vous était imparti voire même
un peu de là donc je vous remercie
j'avais plusieurs questions avant de
laisser la parole à Madame la rapporteur
et les commissaire présent
d'après les paroles de Bernard Monod
économiste du RN alors FN chargée de
lever les fonds auprès des banques la
réussite du premier prêt comme vous
voulez nous l'expliquer accordé aux
parties et soit en majorité du relation
vous avez étissé en Russie
monsieur Monod dit j'avais du mal à
aboutir avec les Russes alors j'ai
demandé un chef à aux heures de
participer il a actionné ses réseaux et
puis trouver un financement comme vous
venez de l'expliquer 8 à cet égard je me
suis tourné vers des amis pouvez-vous
nous en dire plus sur ces relations
amicales et comment vous les avez tissés
sans revenir sur le
voulez-vous que je vous dise de plus je
vais je vais en 2004 traiter pour l'État
français je suis un certain nombre
d'affaires stratégiques pour pour
Dassault également et l'avion du futur
mais ça j'ai pas non plus à vous en
parler je suis quand même lié au secret
bon donc ces relations je les ai oui qui
sont ces amis monsieur 2004
mais quand vous vous êtes consultant
vous avez un engagement je suis désolé
vous devez conseiller votre client et
pas nous parler directement
donc je repose ma question moi je ne
peux pas vous répondre parce que là vous
me posez des questions que la police
judiciaire m'a auquel j'ai répondu je
n'ai pas vous répondre je suis très
clair là-dessus je n'ai pas à vous
répondre ou bien vous vous transformez à
la fois en procureur et en police
judiciaire je connais une période où
cela existé je préfère que qu'elle ne se
reproduise pas je peux vous donner le
nom à quoi à quoi c'était un ami que
j'avais rencontré c'est vrai pour pour
différentes je pourrais vous le donner
mais j'ai pas vous le donner parce que
là franchement dit je pense qu'on sort
de de de
l'État de droit la lettre du ministre la
lettre du ministre de la de la justice à
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
est très claire elle souligne cette
lettre toutes les toutes les comment
puis-je dire les affaires qui sont en
cours et et et et ça ne vous apprendra
rien si je vous donne le nom d'une
personnalité russe qui a été le
président de l'association des banques
régionales et que je connais depuis
longtemps oui mais ça ne vous apprendra
rien bon quelques indications je vous en
remercie nous prenons acte vous ne
voulez pas le citer le nom
j'avais une autre question quelle était
votre rôle dans l'attribution du second
prêt par le RN à ce moment-là d'un
montant de 8 millions d'euros à côté par
Monsieur Laurent Fouchet en 2017 je vous
ai expliqué je vous me disiez Président
je suis désolé que je vous fais perdre
du temps j'ai exprès fait une
présentation générale pour vous faire
pour que vous n'ayez plus à poser des
questions très bien je vous en poser une
autre que vous sur laquelle vous n'êtes
pas exprimé avez-vous joué un rôle dans
l'attribution du prêt de 2 millions
d'euros en 2014 auprès du micro partie
de Jean-Marie Le Pen la côte Elec non
non et non ni de près ni de loin
madame la rapporteur et je reviendrai
vers vous tout à l'heure
j'ai coupé votre micro s'il vous plaît
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur chafouzar je ne commenterai pas
la très longue déclaration à laquelle
vous vous êtes livré précédemment je
souhaiterais juste que la mémoire du
président Chaban-Delmas dans cette
immeuble qui porte son nom soit laissé
au repos voilà tout ce que j'aurais à
dire à ce stade
quels sont la nature de vos
relations avec monsieur Alexandre
babakov et la nature de vos relations
avec monsieur plissiou qui est Monsieur
vorobilliev s'il vous plaît
je peux vous dire mais là encore je
tiens à vous signaler que vous vous
prenez vous prenez
ce sont des questions que la police
judiciaire m'a posé
ce sont des questions vous je sais je
pense que vous vous en rendez compte que
la police judiciaire m'a posé vous vous
que voulez-vous que je vous réponde
alors je peux vous répondre la question
n'est pas là mais je si je vous réponds
si si je vous réponds ça veut dire que
j'accepte qu'il n'y ait plus la
séparation des pouvoirs
donc je peux vous dire que là monsieur
plissu qui était membre de l'Académie
c'est officiel il était signataire de
l'Académie représentait une fondation
russe
et la relation date comme je l'ai dit
indirectement parce qu'il était
président de l'association des banques
régionales
et que les régions russes et que tout ce
qui concerne la Russie je l'ai abordé
aussi sous l'angle de la
décentralisation à l'époque voilà
mais mais mais je vous dis ce sont des
questions qui m'ont été posées
directement par la représentation
nationale le droit de vous poser ces
questions même si vous avez le droit de
pas répondre
oui voilà
merci président de venir un peu à mon
secours voilà
alors vous avez été membre du Parlement
européen
à cette à l'occasion de l'exercice de ce
mandat vous avez souvent été amenés à
vous exprimer sur les sujets de relation
internationales qu'il s'agisse de la
Russie de l'Ukraine de la Syrie tant en
réunion le commission que dans
l'hémicycle vos prises de position ont
été assez régulièrement marqué je ne
pense pas que ce soit vous faire un jour
que le dire par un soutien
à la politique de l'État russe et aux
différentes actions et positions de
l'État russe et particulièrement du
président Poutine vous avez là c'est
facilement à retrouver sur le site du
Parlement européen était très
régulièrement et avec une
opiniâtretée une obstination qu'il faut
souligner le relais d'un certain
narratif russe s'agissant encore une
fois de l'Ukraine par exemple ou de
vision géopolitique mais également
par exemple s'agissant
de la politique du président Bachar
el-Assad tout à fait clairement du côté
du de l'exécutif syrien plutôt que de du
côté de de l'opposition syrienne ça
c'est un fait avéré et sur lequel il est
important
d'insister comme d'ailleurs vous n'étiez
pas le seul membre du Parlement européen
et du groupe de la délégation française
des députés du Front national à être
dans ce narratif et dans ses prises de
position clairement pro russe et pro
Poutine
s'agissant des deux interlocuteurs dont
j'ai cité le nom il y a quelques
instants monsieur plisserie et Monsieur
verrovief il est fait état des échanges
de mails que vous aviez assez
régulièrement avec ses messieurs et
notamment
le 2 juillet 2014 un mail vous aurait
été adressé précisément par Monsieur
vorobière vous transmettant un exemple
de déclaration entre guillemets qui
pourrait être faite dans l'enceinte du
Parlement européen sur la situation en
Ukraine je parle bien de juillet 2014
vous avez
répondu à ce mail que vous alliez
transféré la teneur de ce texte à Madame
Le Pen et que vous alliez considéré ce
texte alors ma question est double
avez-vous transmis le texte de cette
déclaration qui vous était envoyé par
Monsieur vosbien fait qui était
clairement une déclaration pro russe
s'agissant la situation en Ukraine après
les événements que que l'on sait à
Madame Le Pen et pour ce qui est vos
concerne avez-vous dans les prises de
parole que vous avez ensuite effectuées
dans l'enceinte du Parlement européen
relayer les termes et la teneur de cette
déclaration qui vous était transmise par
votre interlocuteur russe monsieur
vorbief
je reviens à mon introduction
ma relation à la Russie ne date pas du
fait que je sois parlementaire
j'y vais en 92
j'y vais en 95
j'y vais en 98 et après j'y vais une
centaine de fois je n'ai pas calculé
j'y vais avec des missions
certaines officielles
quelle politique je développe
celle qui a été celle de la France
puissance d'équilibre
qui depuis le général de Gaulle salit à
la Russie et à la Chine communiste à
l'époque
à la Russie et à la Chine
des accords de coopération bon ben ça
vous je laisserais ça
mais toujours est-il
toujours est-il il faudra en discuter en
historien toujours est-il qui cherche
une puissance d'équilibre je constate
que en 2019 je crois en août 2019 le
président Macron devant les ambassadeurs
prend une position très Collienne je
vous demande simplement de relire ces
propos je vais vous répondre je vais
vous répondre
je vais vous répondre maintenant pour la
Syrie parce que vous avez je viens au
fait mais laissez-moi vous avez votre
question était longue laissez-moi vous
répondre dans sa longueur
sur la Syrie c'est très simple
il s'avère que j'étais
j'ai abandonné ma présidence quand je
suis devenu parlementaire que j'étais
président de l'Institut européen de
coopération et développement et que nous
avons un hôpital en Syrie et que je
connaissais les informations
d'abord par les églises ensuite par nos
équipes qui sont restés là-bas
tout ce que j'avais sur place était pour
le maintien du président
contre les islamistes
dont on a même pu dire qu'ils étaient de
bons alliés de la démocratie
j'oublierai la personne qui l'a dit mais
nous savons tous qui sait
maintenant sur ma position
je vais en 2014 effectivement
dans le dôme basse
commençons par le début
j'appelle le
conseiller à l'Elysée en disant si c'est
feu rouge
je prends
si je peux ne pas y aller on me le dira
on m'a dit
ok
les accords de
je fais une intervention sur les accords
de mince qui est uniquement sur les
accords de Minecraft vous savez il
existe des vidéos là-dessus on peut
reprendre tout ce que je dis
je tiens à rajouter que du côté russe
parce que j'y retournerai après en 2016
on me dit tu ne parles surtout pas
d'indépendance ce qui n'était évidemment
pas mon point de vue puisque les accords
de mise par d'autonomie je sais ce que
ça veut dire n'est-ce pas comme je suis
un spécialiste aussi de la
décentralisation ce que veut dire aussi
les autonomies locales
et je m'en tiens strictement mais
strictement à ses accords
je montre par contre
pourquoi il y a cette guerre
sous faudra pour
ukrainien comme je dis à mes amis
américains parce que je garde des
contacts quand même avec mes amis
américains compris des services
vous êtes américain
vous voyez que l'Allemagne et le premier
importateur exportateur
de la Russie et le premier importateur
est exportateur de la Chine vous n'avez
pas le choix
vous êtes obligé de casser cet axe
continental qui vous marginalise
totalement
vous êtes obligé c'est une question un
peu de vie ou de mort les conséquences
des conséquences
nous verrons ce sera pour moi la fin de
l'Empire c'est la fin de l'empire
américain mais ça c'est autre chose mais
à court terme quand vous voyez cet axe
constituée vous n'avez pas le choix
brézinsky le formalisent dès 1997 et ne
met pas en considération et ne met pas
en considération la Chine la Chine
change tout
on arrive et donc maintenant pour
revenir à votre question particulière
auxquelles j'ai déjà répondu d'une part
à l'enquête et d'autre part devant les
médias
sur la 2
je me suis amusé c'est une mauvaise
manière de répondre mais je vous
répondrai à regarder toutes les
personnes du Parlement qui étaient liées
à la fondation Soros
le nombre nous arrivions au chiffre
quasiment de 200
fondations dont je montrais clairement
lors d'une étude présentée devant mes
amis parlementaires qu'elle avait donné
tous les éléments de langage
avant même
l'ouverture des frontières de
l'immigration qui ont va être repris par
des chefs d'État
de mon côté
j'ai parmi les membres de l'Académie
européenne
des représentants russes ils s'adressent
à moi il me demande que dites-vous vous
êtes toujours poli
nous prendrons ça en considération
évidemment qu'on prend ça en
considération prend ça en considération
par rapport à
j'ai défendu regardez mes interventions
dites-moi quand je suis allé contre la
position française je suis allé contre
la position française c'est vrai
sur la Syrie mais parce que la
production française est faite de
une faudrait une enquête parlementaire
là
écoutez les évêques moi j'étais en
première ligne là-bas vous pouvez le
savoir l'hôpital
d'Alep
bon donc moi j'avais des informations
mais sur le reste
moi en quoi j'ai pris j'ai pris des
positions contraires à celle de mon pays
dites moi
je suis je suis
le micro s'il vous plaît
je vais revenir à votre rôle de
d'entremetteurs ou d'intermédiaires ou
de négociateur pour l'obtention des
prérusses entre guillemets pour le Front
national donc le premier en 2014 donc
contracté auprès de la firstate washing
Bang qui est une petite banque
effectivement créée en je voudrais
terminer s'il vous plaît sans être
interrompu non non mais voilà créer en
1996 en Tchéquie mais très rapidement
transférer à Moscou parce que reprise
par le géant russe
strodia transgans je parle très mal le
Russe évidemment une grosse entreprise
russe leader dans la construction de
gazoduc et cette banque entre guillemets
first chat Russian bascule sous le
contrôle d'un monsieur Popov ancien
cadre bancaire de la sphère étatique a
d'ailleurs depuis les déboires de la
Forestière
totalement disparu de la circulation
alors il se trouve que
toutes les banques entre guillemets
enfin tous les prêteurs russes auxquels
le Front National a eu recours et donc
vous êtes
forcément à en connaître puisque vous en
avez été l'intermédiaire ont connu des
déboires ont disparu on fait faillite
ont connu des déboires judiciaires donc
c'est le cas de la firstation dingue
donc la créance est transmise dans les
conditions extraordinairement bizarres
et extraordinairement
étrange d'ailleurs qui vont finir par
s'avérer être considéré comme
frauduleuse y compris par la justice
russe elle-même a une obscure petite
société moscovite qu'on appelle Conti
qui est une société installée dans la
banlieue de Moscou et connu pour faire
de la location de voiture et de matériel
et puis après la créance russe entre
guillemets du Front national se balade
de Conti à une autre banque parce que
quand il elle aussi s'avère être
en boire une coquille vide qui disparaît
de la circulation et et on se retrouve
avec le transfert de la créance vers une
autre société qui elle pour le coup
n'est pas une coquille vide qui
s'appelle aviasapchat qui est une
société d'aéronautique d'aéronautique
contrôlé par l'ancien militaires proche
des services secrets russes et qui est
plutôt spécialisé dans la maintenance et
la réparation d'avions et d'hélicoptère
double usage civils et militaires et qui
travaillent notamment à la modernisation
pas que mais notamment à la modernation
de la flotte aéronautique civile de
Syrie
voilà qu'avez-vous à dire sur les
séquences extrêmement
troublantes de déboires judiciaires de
disparition et de
transfert dans des conditions souvent un
peu rocobolesques mystérieuse de la
créance
du
pré russe accordé au
Front national d'une structure à l'autre
et avez-vous connaissance en réalité de
l'origine des fonds parce que il y a
véritablement souvent une question à se
poser sur l'origine des fonds vous avez
la parole par contre appuyez sur le
micro merci
lorsque j'ai changé en cours de
mandature je comptais en 2014 arrêter
mes activités de consultants par la
suite j'ai reprises je leur fais une
déclaration dans ce sens là
je suis élu je crois en mai mais juin
nous sommes en 2014 vous étiez collègues
et
je ne suis plus à faire
c'est à dire que je vais jusqu'au stade
et je croyais moi que que moi-même je
suis étonné pas étonné parce que je
connais les affaires russes je pouvais
évidemment pas savoir l'évolution de
cette banque qui avait une licence
européenne
donc à partir du je ne suis pas la
signature qui a lieu un peu plus
tardivement c'est mon avocat qui me
représente et c'est lui qui suivra
jusqu'au transfert des fonds après
nous ne intervenons plus
ce que je peux vous dire parce que je
connais l'histoire russe je crois qu'il
y a eu
plusieurs centaines de banquiers
et quand vous êtes en face d'histoire
russe vous avez toujours des
liquidations des problèmes des actifs et
des actifs qui
mais vous savez vous n'êtes pas obligé
d'aller regarder les Russes vous pouvez
regarder également chez nous quand il y
a une dissolution d'une entreprise et
l'active comment ceci se balade et
comment quelquefois ils enrichit
quelques-uns je crois même qu'il y a des
enquêtes en cours sur 50 milliards qui
auraient disparu comme 15 milliards 15
milliards 15 milliards qui auraient dont
on sait pas très bien en France donc
bon moi
il y a eu un point de rupture
mais là marine avait raison Marine Le
Pen excusez-moi la Présidente il y a eu
un point de rupture moi moi j'aurais
souhaité
en 2014 il pouvait rembourser
j'aurais souhaité qu'on provisionne
le prêt telle manière qu'on soit sûr à
pouvoir le rembourser dans les délais
de fait le rassemblement national à
l'époque faisait 2 millions de déficits
il fallait qu'il fasse 2 millions
d'excédents pour rembourser
cela impliqué qu'on divise par deux la
masse salariale
Marine Le Pen m'avait d'abord suivi dans
cette direction et j'ai commencé à
regarder les comptes en état et avoir où
on pouvait qu'est-ce qu'il fallait faire
et puis en fin de compte elle l'a pas
fait puis de fait elle a eu raison parce
que moi je suis raisonné en terme
comptable
il y a un prêt pour le rembourser si on
dégage pas de millions d'excédents on
n'arrivera pas à le rembourser et elle
elle résonnait en termes politiques et
dynamique politique celle casser son
instrument elle n'aurait pas aujourd'hui
autant de députés
donc moi je m'en suis tenu à mon rôle on
s'est fâché c'est vrai j'ai dit
publiquement que je n'étais pas d'accord
mais c'est elle qui avait raison
parce que si elle m'avait écouté elle
aurait cassé son instrument et elle ne
serait pas arrivée là où elle est donc
maintenant
elle comme moi alors moi encore je suis
venu mais mais on a dû faire avec m'a
posé la question je vous le dis aussi je
serai pas obligé de le vous dire
qu'est-ce qu'on fait j'ai dit on met on
met l'argent on le remboursement sous un
séquestre en attendant d'y voir clair
c'est ce que nous avons fait c'est à
dire que Laura semblement national a
continué de payer ce qu'il pouvait sous
séquestre jusqu'à ce qu'on sache où doit
aller
l'argent en question que derrière ces
centaines de banques qui est des choses
un peu bizarres
je vous l'accorde mais c'est pas
uniquement en Russie
des choses bizarres je vous donne acte
de cette appréciation
[Musique]
vous n'aviez pas tout à fait arrêté de
suivre les les affaires entre guillemets
puisque
vous avez en juin 2017 à nouveau été
l'intermédiaire pour avec je crois un
homme d'affaires français Laurent
Foucher parvenir à la conclusion d'un
prêt de 8 millions d'euros contracter
cette fois-ci auprès d'une banque une
structure appelée Nour capitale basée
aux Émirats arabes unis là aussi est-ce
que donc vous étiez en situation d'être
activement
l'intermédiaire aux côtés de ce monsieur
Laurent Foucher pour la contraction de
ce nouveau prêt de 2-8 millions pour
permettre au rassemblement national de
fin Front national encore à l'époque de
de faire face
à son endettement effectivement
et donc vous ne vous êtes pas plus
intéressé à l'origine des fonds qui
alimentait le capital de cette banque
entre guillemets Nour capitale et qui
aurait
ensuite été
l'objet du prêt donné au prêter aux
parties vos informations viennent de
journalistes d'abord comme je vous l'ai
dit 2014 2016 je veux interrompre en
2016 se pose la question à ce que je
reste parlementaire je reste pas
parlementaire je finis mon mandat je
finis pas mon mandat je suis en certains
partent moi je pars pas c'est pas mon
affaire et si je partais je donnais mon
siège
c'était très clair je fais pas comme les
autres qui sont restés en profitant de
la rémunération moi je quittais donc
pour mon indépendance financière je le
reprends mon activité pour être libre
ce n'est pas
l'affaire comme je voulais dire ce
contexte que vous vous croyez que je
vous abusez monsieur le Président en
disant que je vous abusez en donnant un
de dire que j'amuse
que moi je vous abusais que moi je vous
abusé moi je dis pas que vous m'appuyez
moi je vous abuse
c'était bien pour expliquer ce contexte
en l'occurrence il s'agit au
présidentiel
aucune banque ne veut prêter ni au
rassemblement national ni à Marine Le
Pen pourtant elle est sûre puisque
marine a fait plus de 5% je crois
donc
comme je vous l'ai dit et les documents
sont là
il existait un prêt aux Philippines
bloqué au dernier moment
à ce moment-là on présente une personne
qui avait des actifs
et qui étaient prêtes à
apporter son soutien
et bien
à partir du moment donné ou
non capitale qui est une structure qui
continue
à fonctionner qui a la licence émirative
qui traite des affaires d'état
vous m'entendez bien pour le compte de
l'État émirati
à partir du moment donné où
ces actifs étaient considérés en
garantie suffisante
pour pouvoir faire si par hasard il y
avait un problème
pour que la banque considère que c'est
une sécurité
ce n'est plus mon problème
pourquoi Monsieur Foucher l'a fait parce
qu'il était rémunéré également il avait
le pourcentage intéressant et puis
il a fait partie du deal global de cette
affaire donc
c'était une question sinon la présidente
se trouvait en faillite personnelle ou
en très grande difficulté
à nouveau par l'intervention d'une
puissance étrangère par l'intervention
d'une puissance étrangère aucune banque
qui veulent prêter qu'on a préparé le
dossier tout est là et au dernier moment
le seul représentant étranger
c'est-à-dire liés aux États-Unis fait
son veto bon donc par intervention
étrangère c'est une affaire qui m'a
profondément oui je n'accepte pas ça
vous me l'entendez bien je ne l'accepte
pas ça aurait été quelqu'un d'autre que
Marine ça aurait été exactement la même
chose
j'ai une dernière question et puis après
on fera tourner la parole je vous
entends nous vous entendons dire à
plusieurs reprises et avec beaucoup de
véhémentes que pour vous la question est
celle que aucune banque
occidentale ne voulait prêter à Madame
Le Pen je mets beaucoup de guillemets au
Front national peut-être cela a-t-il à
voir quand même aussi un peu avec
certains débats de gestion donc par
exemple l'affaire Jeanne rival a
récemment illustré quand même les
dysfonctionnements bon je n'irai pas
plus loin parce que la justice française
est saisie la cour d'appel de Paris
vient de se prononcer de manière assez
sévère d'ailleurs sur le micro parti
Jeanne de manha Le Pen et j'irai pas
plus loin mais enfin il y a clairement
des difficultés de gestion pour ne pas
dire plus qui sont avérés qui peuvent
peut-être expliquer alors que d'autres
formations politiques en France trouve à
être
accompagné financièrement par des
banques dont on peut peut-être trouver
là une explication j'en viens juste à ma
question est-ce que vous n'avez pas
penser imaginer que
l'intérêt d'un sombre de
donne d'affaires russes de prêteurs
russes pour l'entreprise politique de
Madame Le Pen et le Front national
était motivé aussi par l'envie de
pouvoir avoir une certaine prise sur un
positionnement une ligne politique avoir
en quelque sorte un vecteur plus que
d'influence de véritables
allégeance ou en tout cas
alliance politique idéologique tant au
Parlement européen que dans d'autres
sphères de la vie politique est-ce qu'il
n'y a pas là quelque chose qui peut
venir en réflexion chez vous vous avez
la parole il y a plusieurs choses
d'abord
conformer deux choses le parti marine
c'est pas la même chose là ça aurait pu
être un prêt personnel pour des raisons
techniques nous avons fait un prêt qui
passait bon par
prêt aux parties qui lui-même
prêté à Marine
donc ça ça n'intervient pas ça
maintenant vous connaissez mon point de
vue je vous l'ai exprimer j'étais pour
qu'on fasse des excédents et qu'on
divise par deux les dépenses
mais en l'occurrence pour le deuxième
prêt ça n'intervient pas et pour 2014
en 2014 le rassemblement national à la
capacité de rembourser je vois les
comptes
objectifs
que moi
donc
maintenant inverser les choses
il y a un prêt américain
et il y a une officine russe qui dévoile
le prêt américain
pour montrer que
c'est scandaleux la pression des
Américains sur la manière dont ils
essayent de prendre la main de mettre la
main sur la droite et l'extrême droite
bon
tout le monde se retourne contre cette
officine qui dénonce
et non pas sur le fait que une banque
américaine prête
donc vous voyez
tout tout est inversé en l'occurrence ce
qui est grave
c'est comment une puissance
internationale qui tient la finance
occidentale utilise de son pouvoir pour
intervenir pour intervenir dans les
affaires intérieures et politiques d'un
pays
considérant que tel est-elle à droite et
que telle et telle autre n'a pas le
droit
maintenant
ne confondez pas
2016-2017 plutôt avec 2014 ces deux
choses complètement différentes
il y a aucune puissance étrangère en
2017 aucune
aucune
aucune à moins que vous vouliez les
Colisée Mira menant je sais que mes amis
de nous se sont font un peu taper sur
les doigts parce qu'ils ont fait ça
parce que certains sont des amis de
longue date
mais mais
donc
en 2014 je vous ai déjà dit on aurait pu
faire et là je
on aurait pu trouver d'autres solutions
ça nous a paru et franchement dit
nous étions mettons pas 2014 mettons
2013 nous étions pas dans le contexte
déjà de maïdan nous préparons il faut
prendre un an en recul un peu plus d'un
an parce qu'il y a l'affaire d'Abou
Dhabi qui n'aboutit pas donc
mettez-vous à notre place franchement
sincèrement il n'y a pas
nous nous serions trouvé dans un autre
parti vous savez que je suis pas
vous m'empêcherez pas que j'ai quand
même été adhérentes pan Europe et que
ils vont Bourges est un ami et que c'est
vrai que officiellement je suis resté
administrateur territorial pour des
raisons de fonction alliées à la
fonction publique entre 86 et 88 mais
que j'étais proche de Chaban que c'était
un ami il m'a même écrit de son propre
de sa propre à certains nombres donc je
vous dis que dans d'autres parties je
suis pas un homme de partie je n'ai pas
adhéré moi rassemblement national
pourquoi j'ai repris mon activité de
2016 c'est parce que je veux rester un
homme libre partir à tout moment comme
quand j'ai été fonctionnaire donc je
vous dis n'importe qui d'autre aurait
pris la même décision entre la Chine et
l'Iran la Russie pour une banque avec
licence européenne bon après ce qu'est
devenu cette banque tout ça on n'était
pas Madame on était pas Madame Soleil
mais comme je vous l'ai dit il y a eu
plusieurs centaines
peut-être même milliers
de suppression de banque en Russie très
bien vous remercions pour cette réponse
madame la rapporteur vous avez terminé
pour la question merci à ce stade donc
avant de passer la parole aux autres
rapporteurs en fait je voulais rebondir
sur sur un nouveau propos tout à l'heure
et un point que je voulais évoquer vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure que un moment
donné vous étiez fâché un petit peu avec
Madame Le Pen et je crois comprendre que
vous aviez refusé de trouver un
troisième prêt par la suite et que cela
peut être vous a peut-être empêcher
d'être candidat aux élections
européennes de 2019 est-ce que vous
pouvez nous éclairer sur ce sujet
quand vous faites un prêt c'est pas le
rembourser
si je sais pertinemment que dans la
situation évidemment je pouvais pas
deviner que
demain ils auraient un groupe avec 89
députés ils auraient pu en avoir 90
d'ailleurs
si je vis c'était candidat dans les
Vosges mais
vous pouvez pas savoir donc quand vous
savez que il peut pas rembourser vous
prêtez pas
parce que sinon vous savez en 40 ans de
vie professionnelle c'est la parole et
la transparence sinon vous n'avez plus
d'amis
vous perdez beaucoup de choses et bien
donc j'ai été très honnête j'ai dit dans
ces conditions je peux pas
vous savez pas faire de mandat j'ai en
2016 j'ai failli partir donc franchement
et donc
ça ne change rien mais je ne regrette
pas je ne regrette pas le combat
si c'était à refaire je referai tout
vous m'entendez bien et si c'était à
refaire pour quelqu'un d'autre qui se
trouve dans la même situation je le
ferai également
oui mais vous répondez pas totalement à
ma question ce que je voulais juste
savoir c'est est-ce que vous pensez que
votre refus que vous avez très bien
expliqué de
d'essayer de trouver un nouveau prêt
puisqu'il était pas remboursable le
reste n'était pas remboursable est-ce
que cela vous a empêché d'être candidat
en 2019
oui oui je crois oui je crois
oui
très bien nous avons la réponse à la
question je pense nous allons passer je
vous demande de raccrocher votre micro
s'il vous plaît nous allons passer la
parole monsieur monsieur Tanguy s'il
vous plaît
merci monsieur le Président ma première
question je voudrais revenir à votre
rôle en fait tout simplement dans la
négociation de ces prêts notamment le
principal prêt le premier de 9 millions
d'euros c'est la mémoire est bonne
puisque nous avons interrogé le
président de la Commission nationale des
comptes de campagne du financement des
partis politiques dessus et j'aimerais
comprendre dans le cadre de cette
négociation
quelle était en fait vos objectifs
simplement financiers c'est-à-dire avec
qu'est-ce que vous avez espéré négocier
avec quel taux d'intérêt ce que vous
estimez que le taux d'intérêt que vous
avez obtenu était excusez-moi votre
avocat vous parle pendant que je vous
parle est-ce que vous estimez que votre
taux le taux d'intérêt était correct par
rapport au marché par rapport à ce qu'on
aurait pu attendre d'un financement
normal est-ce qu'il était favorable
défavorable vous avez une appréciation
sur ce sur ce taux et j'aimerais aussi
mieux comprendre
cette commission vous avez parlé la
commission que vous avez touché vous
aussi bien compris défraiement mais
ensuite vous allez parler s'il est bien
compris une fois de plus de sur ses sens
140 000 euros de 70 000 euros de frais
avocat déplacement et donc 70 000 euros
est-ce que ça correspond à d'autres
frais ou est-ce que ça correspond à une
comment le qualifier dans ce pure
d'activité que je ne connais pas d'un
bénéfice personnel ou d'un bénéfices
professionnels
normalement pas à vous répondre je suis
désolé
vous vous venez
mettre me signal justement que je vais
vous répondre sur une question technique
le taux était un taux élevé c'est pour
ça
mais correspondait au taux minimum
c'était le taux de base bancaire
donc
ce n'était pas ce n'était pas un mauvais
c'était un mauvais taux si on comparé à
la France mais c'était pas un mauvais
mot évidemment ou à une autre
institution
occidentale mais c'était un taux minimum
qui n'était pas de faveur non plus
puisque sinon il aurait été sous le
marché c'est le taux de marché minimum
voilà
j'ai pu montrer que depuis
1982 je mène une activité de consultant
également
et donc
et croyez moi j'avais l'habitude de
facturer dès l'année
enfin à partir de l'année 2000 entre
3000 et 5000 euros la journée
dès lors je suis bien en dessous si
j'avais facturé à ce prix là des taux
que je pratique habituellement auprès
des entreprises
merci je suis Tanguy d'autres questions
votre micro s'il vous plaît
excusez-moi monsieur j'ai posé la
question parce que vous-même avez
introduit dans cette commission
l'élément là j'ai envie de dire la
répartition que vous estimiez avoir fait
de ces 140000 euros donc je m'étonne que
vous vouliez apporter une partie de la
raid une information à cette commission
sans vouloir répondre à la deuxième
partie puisque c'est vous qui avez parlé
de ça c'est pas moi donc à partir du
moment où vous avez introduit cette
information je pense que c'est pas
normal de pas nous expliquer à quoi
correspond ces 70 000 autres euros et je
n'ai pas fini de de poser ma question et
donc il y a une question assise dans la
suite de cette négociation de ce prêt
est-ce que vous avez eu à connaître ou
est-ce que vous connaissez ou est-ce que
c'est vous-même qu'il avait fait des
démarches fait pour que ce prêt soit
déclaré aux autorités françaises pour
que la somme soit versée dans des
conditions qui a postériori ont été
validées par toutes les autorités
compétentes est-ce que vous avez été
associé à ces démarches là ou est-ce que
c'est le rassemblement le Front national
ou les oui parce que c'est après ou
partie le Front national qui s'est
occupé
du bon recensement et du bon déroulement
du transfert des fonds dans le respect
de la loi puisque tout a été validé
ces sommes ont été évidemment
fiscalement
ce qui me concerne tous ces faits de
manière régulière d'ailleurs croyez moi
que si les choses n'avaient pas été
faites de manière régulière j'aurais été
mise en examen
il y a eu quand même c'est vrai une
enquête judiciaire
qui commence en 2016
qui n'est pas
close semble-t-il
mais
je ne suis pas mise en examen à ce jour
et si je le
peux vous dire que tout a été fait j'ai
derrière moi 40 ans de vie
professionnelle en traitant des dossiers
extrêmement sensibles
6 sous quelques formes que ce soit je
m'étais amusé à planquer de l'argent à
ne pas déclarer etc
je devenais une cible
autrement dit on me faisait chanter les
services américains les services russes
les services chinois
pour dire ou bien tu travailles avec
nous ou bien on dévoile telle et telle à
faire
le principe de ma vie professionnelle
c'est 40 ans de vie de professionnels
quand j'étais auprès je m'excuse auprès
de ma mais auprès de Bernard Stasi entre
86 et 88 et que je l'accompagnais à
l'Élysée et que j'en cerisais m'aimait
beaucoup
badige Jean-Luc voulait être un homme
d'État je m'excuse je m'excuse je le dis
comme il l'a dit jamais d'histoire de
cul jamais d'histoire de fric
et bien
je me suis tenu pendant 40 ans plus de
40 ans de vie professionnelle je pense
n'avoir jamais eu d'histoire de Kun et
d'histoire de fric parce que le jour
où vous savez lorsque j'étais en Russie
parce que j'étais en Russie la première
fois me donne une assistante magnifique
qui me dit qu'elle est posée plutôt la
question vos aventures nous intéresse
pas non mais je vous dis que donc c'est
le principe même de la liberté
le principe même de la liberté et de
pouvoir servir
sinon vous n'êtes pas libre et c'est
bien le problème
de la politique française depuis 40 ans
après du général de Gaulle
non c'est pas mon point de vue ça
commence avec eux ça commence déjà avec
Pompidou lorsque lorsque De Gaulle
lorsque De Gaulle veut faire la
participation pour son s'il vous plaît
vous je suis désolé monsieur
je vais peut-être moi ma question était
pas claire
ma question était c'est pas de vous
reprocher des choses délictuelles ou
délictueuses donc c'est pas l'objet
d'une enquête et de ses suites que
j'ignore ma question c'est justement
dans le cadre légal qui a existé puisque
tout a été
reconnu et que les autorités françaises
n'ont pas fait grief sur le déroulement
de ce prêt ces conditions justement
légales et opérationnelles c'est que je
puis dire donc ma question c'est est-ce
que vous avez été associé à ces
opérations pour qu'elle soit légale
est-ce que vous nous les décrire parce
qu'il y a il y a si vous voulez il y a
une zone d'ombre aujourd'hui entre le
moment où le prêt a été obtenu dans des
conditions que vous avez rappelé sur
lesquels vous avez été dérogés et le
moment cet argent a été versé comment
était versé et le moment où tout ça a
été validé nous ne savons pas ce qui
s'est passé entre le prêt a été obtenu
et le moment où c'est tout ça a été
considéré comme légal
je n'ai pas là maintenant je peux pas
vous répondre directement parce que j'ai
pas une mémoire du tout mais le
versement des 140 000 c'est fait
jour après la signature
il y a pas de et
ma mission s'arrête là
si j'ai à vous répondre c'est ça
le rassemblement national signe une
lettre comme quoi je peux m'adresser à
la partie bancaire
que je peux facturer 140000 et et
je facture 140000
à la structure qu'on me propose et
mettons bien
prairus etc et conformément à
l'autorisation que j'avais du côté du
rassemblement national et cela se fait
dans les 15 jours par plusieurs mois
après
voilà
une autre question
oui merci monsieur le Président mon
autre question c'est évidemment sur les
accusations qui ont été faites par voie
de presse et dans un certain nombre de
débats politiques sur les contreparties
qu'il y aurait eu à peu près donc
négociateur vous êtes on a fait part
d'un certain nombre de mails
est-ce que oui ou non dans le cadre de
cette négociation avant et dans la
réalisation de ce prêt après
est-ce que oui ou non il y a eu des
demandes de contrepartie politique à
savoir des prises de position de
responsables du Front national ou non
évidemment que non je vous ai répondu
nous nous en tenons à ce que la
politique de la France j'ai dit regardez
le discours du président Macron devant
les ambassadeurs je crois que maintenant
je sais plus si c'est en août 2019
il faut le relire
dites moi en quoi cette position diffère
de celle du président de la République
par exemple nous sommes en 2019 oui mais
là nous sommes pas en 2019 là nous
sommes en 2014 il n'y a pas encore eu la
signature il y a pas encore eu
l'opération Crimée excusez-moi les temps
je les connais
nous n'en sont pas s'il vous plaît dans
un débat
je refuse d'aller en Crimée vous
constaterez quand même on m'invite en
Crimée je refuse d'y aller j'y vais pas
moi personnellement
je vais dans le Dombas mais je demande
alors personne pourra dire que je l'ai
pas demandé de cetera je vous prie sur
l'honneur que j'ai demandé et si on
m'avait dit feu rouge je n'y allais pas
manifer orange tu défends les accords
d'accord donc j'apprends par hasard que
c'était pour faire semblant mais ça
c'est une autre histoire
OK
c'est Tanguy la réponse à votre question
oui partiellement dans les reproches
enfin les accusations qui sont portées
entre le lien entre l'obtention de ce
prêt et les prises de position de
responsables du Front national il y a
les mails qui ont été évoqués mais
j'estime que la réponse parce qu'elle
est souvent longue monsieur et je pense
que
je pense qu'on gagnerait parfois à non
non j'ai pas fini à écourter pour que
les réponses soient claires parce que
c'est très difficile pour tous les
membres de cette commission vu la
sensibilité des sujets d'avoir parfois
des analyses précises de ce qui s'est
passé dans un sens ou dans l'autre
est-ce que oui ou non on
personnalités vous ont transmis un
communiqué écrit par eux que vous avez
reçu qui a été transmis à une d'autres
personnalités de ration nationale un
Front National et qui ont été sortis
comme tel ou oui vous avez reçu un
communiqué et vous en avez fait ce que
vous voulez et aucune autre personnalité
dure à son scène ne l'a repris comme tel
non non seulement vous avez raison de
souligner ça
non seulement
personne n'a transmis j'ai transmis ceci
à la présidente la preuve c'est pas moi
qui ai traité cette opération
l'assistant parlementaire si c'est
nécessaire pour moi j'ai filé l'affaire
je lui disant tu regardes bon j'ai pas
donné d'instruction
il n'y a pas eu d'influence et je je ne
je m'excuse là maintenant de parler d'un
point de vue personnel lorsque j'ai été
député marine m'a donné
Marine Le Pen m'a donné la capacité
d'abord elle n'est jamais intervenue
je n'ai jamais eu besoin de
de demander l'autorisation etc et je
mets intervenu j'ai une liberté totale
et et je lui ensurai
autrement dit s'il y avait eu un
coupable plutôt plus suite été témoin
mais moi-même je n'ai pas pris cette
intervention lorsqu'il s'agissait
d'intervenir sur le sujet en plein air
sur ces questions c'est un de mes
assistants qui a fait l'intervention et
pas sur ordre
je donc
franchement dit là là vous savez
on prend ce prétexte pour dire voilà
j'étais sous influence bon il y a
beaucoup de personnes qui peuvent vous
écrire pour vous demander vous
solliciter quelque chose vous leur dites
pas
bon
vous leur dit très bien bon et vous vous
en faites qu'à votre tête ce qui vous
semble juste c'est pour ça que je vous
demande d'en mettre toutes mes
interventions dites moi une fois une
position qui était contraire à la
position de la France
très bien sauf sur la Syrie je suis
d'accord avec vous mais pas sur la
Russie pas sur la Russie très bien
merci de fermer votre micro je vais
passer si Monsieur Tanguy a terminé
on enchaîne sinon on passait la parole à
Charles
merci monsieur le Président
j'ai plusieurs petites questions à poser
à Monsieur chaffauder avant en
introduction je voudrais dire au micro
ce que j'ai dit un peu à l'emporter
avant parce que ça me semble important
moi j'aimerais que
l'ancien élus une extrême droite cesse
de convoquer le général de Gaulle à
chaque fois pour se défendre de leur
turpitude et vraiment
d'utiliser la figure du général qui a
combattu l'histoire enfin votre famille
politique
prédécesseur de la famille politique à
laquelle pour laquelle pour laquelle
pour laquelle vous avez été investi vous
avez été membre du groupe au Parlement
européen pendant 5 ans vraiment je pense
que ça ça fait très mal à beaucoup de
personnes
[Musique]
je voulais juste en 30 secondes quand
même rectifier ça sur le sur l'emprunt
russe
qui vous a missionné au Front national
sur ce sujet
la présidence et son trésorier ce qui
est normal c'est les empreintes relèvent
de la présidente et du trésorier
notre micro
avez-vous eu à traiter avec d'autres
personnes au sein du Front national du
sujet de l'emprunt russe ou vous en
discutiez simplement avec Madame Le Pen
et son trésorier
j'en ai même pas Bernard Monod une fois
que Bernard avait fait la je n'ai pas eu
l'occasion non je traçais avec la
présidente et le trésorier enfin c'est
tout
merci sa réponse très claire
j'ai
visionné le
reportage qui vous était en partie
consacré cet automne par le service
public et il me semble mais c'est pour
ça que je voulais vous reposer la
question ici donc que vous avez affirmé
avoir rencontré Monsieur Poutine par le
passé c'est ça
je crois que je me suis jamais exprimé
sur ces questions là et vous pouvez
vérifier ça
ni je parle des plus hautes autorités de
l'État jamais jamais vous m'avez entendu
dire ça
je n'en n'était pas certain c'est pour
ça que je voulais vous poser la question
il me semble aussi que vous avez dit à
l'occasion de se reportage que la Russie
ou le régime de Monsieur Poutine avait
une certaine façon intérêt à faire ce
prêt pour avoir des alliés
occidentaux est-ce que vous pouvez vous
expliquer sur cette phrase qui c'est un
jugement politique
il est certain on pose la question à ce
que la Russie était le pouvoir en place
c'était qui au courant je dis évidemment
que si le pouvoir remplace était contre
l'affaire ne se serait pas faite
constatons aussi que le pouvoir
américain décide
que
aucun une banque occidentale ne peut
prêter au rassemblement national ou au
front nationaux
pensons pas mes allégations vous savez
40 ans de vie professionnelle quand
j'affirme des choses je sais de quoi je
parle tu sais de quoi je pars
sur notre sujet donc
quelle est la politique du président
Poutine la politique de du président
Poutine a toujours été de avoir d'être
une politique eurasienne
donc se méfier de la Chine malgré tout
parce que ça représente un danger vu la
puissance
quand je suis allé en Chine je suis
passé par Moscou avant d'aller en Chine
pour les entreprises françaises pour
mieux comprendre la Chine
avec l'autorisation évidemment
donc c'est et d'avoir des alliés
occidentaux comme ça vous êtes en
équilibre pour mener vos intérêts
si la politique un peu de la France de
l'Atlantique à l'oral par rapport à
l'Asie par rapport aux États-Unis
bon
sincèrement le président Poutine que je
suis de 2000 à
2000 à chercher cette alliance
occidentale
et
parce qu'elle est
de politique d'équilibre dans l'intérêt
de la Russie et que je crois aussi que
les pour nous aussi dans l'intérêt
ce qu'on parle de la l'Atlantique à
l'oral à l'époque la Russie était
communiste
elle aussi dans l'intérêt de la France
pour d'autres raisons la géopolitique
dicte d'une certaine manière vos
intérêts
et donc il était normal que le président
essaie tout état c'est ce que je m'étais
en introduction qu'on m'a coupé parce
qu'il y en avait pour beaucoup plus
je laisserai si vous le souhaitez le
texte
j'expliquais ça donc c'est il y a rien
de choquant
j'ai travaillé avec mes amis israéliens
c'était dans l'intérêt d'Israël
bon
la Russie travaille dans l'intérêt de la
Russie
et je n'ai jamais travaillé ça c'était
tout au début quand j'étais le
représentant des par la suite j'ai
toujours travaillé pour les sociétés
françaises jamais travaillé pour une
société étrangère jamais et j'ai eu des
offres croyez moi extrêmement
intéressante elle a chute du Mur les
Américains m'ont offert un pont en or
avec des montants
très importants j'ai d'ailleurs donné
ceci c'est dans les archives de nos
services
bon
peut-être je serai aujourd'hui sans
doute une personne très fortunée mais
bon j'ai fait un choix
donc ça me paraît pas absurde que que
non seulement pas absurde ça me paraît
logique que la Russie sert les intérêts
de Russie donc cherche des alliés
occidentaux comme elle se sert ça me
paraissait mais directement non
directement non
d'ailleurs s'il y avait eu je vais plus
loin cette pression là
dans l'intérêt de la présidente mais
aussi de mon pays on aurait trouvé une
autre solution
on aurait trouvé une autre solution pour
aller pour aller jusqu'au bout de la
question de du commissaire avez-vous
rencontré Monsieur Poutine
ça me paraît important
c'est dans le cadre professionnel je
n'ai pas à vous répondre là j'ai le
système
obligé je je n'ai pas à titre personnel
que je l'ai rencontré comme élu donc
vous avouez que vous l'avez rencontré je
ne l'ai pas rencontré comme élu
et et et donc on pourrait me reprocher
j'ai lu vos papiers
dévoilement de secret professionnel et
on pourrait me reprocher un certain
nombre de choses je je
n'ai pas à vous répondre je ne peux pas
vous répondre sur ce sujet
professionnel vous venez de dire juste
avant que vous défendez que vous avez
toujours défendu les intérêts de la
France quand je parle de secret
professionnel je parle des intérêts d'un
certain nombre de sociétés qui sont qui
travaillent pour la France en tout cas
nous avons entendu que vous n'avez pas
rencontré dans ce cadre là donc on peut
comprendre que vous l'avez rencontré
soit n'a rien à voir par rapport oui
c'est vrai enfin bon très bien merci
pour votre réponse
poursuivez merci pour pour ces réponses
très claires très très instructif
est-ce que vous pouvez juste nous
rappeler pour le premier prêt de 2014
quand se passe dans l'année 2014 le
finalisation en closing de ce prêt
j'ai plus je peux pas
bon il y a rien de techniquement je suis
déjà parlementaire
donc je peux pas je peux pas je n'y vais
pas à cause de ça parce que j'ai dit que
je ne j'arrêtais donc je suis
c'est déjà mon avocat qui suit tout qui
connaît parfaitement le dossier qui le
connaît même mieux que moi entre nous
voilà
donc après après mais mais après pour
des raisons l'affaire était bien
antérieure
puisqu'elle s'est préparée bien avant ce
genre de presse ça prend du temps mais
mais techniquement oui ça doit être juin
sans doute oui moi j'ai pu en tête la
date mais je suis déjà parlementaire
merci c'était une réponse claire je
voulais juste cette information du coup
j'en reviens à des sujets un petit peu
politiques parce que vous ne cessez de
dire dans cette audition où vous avez
suivi fidèlement la politique de la
France enfin moi je peux pas vous
permettre de dire ça parce que je vous
rappelle que l'annexion de la Crimée par
la Fédération de Russie a lieu à partir
de la fin du mois de février 2014
que la France par la voix de son
président
ne soutient pas et condamne cette
addiction et qu'ensuite le référendum
illégal sur
cette annexion de la Crimée par la
Russie a lieu
en mars
2014 donc j'aimerais que vous nous
expliquer en quoi
le parti politique pour lequel vous
travaillez vous collaborez sans en être
formellement adhérent mais vous l'aidiez
en tout cas le parti politique Front
national prend position en mars 2014
pour pour cette annexion donc
expliquez-moi en quoi tout ça était
fidèle à la politique de la France et
vous avez travaillé en défendant les
intérêts de la politique de la France
en commission des affaires étrangères je
suis intervenu sur la Crimée
et j'ai dit que nous sommes en face
d'une difficulté juridique
le droit à l'autodétermination qui est
un droit international
et puis d'autre part les frontières
intangibles
maintenant dans aucune des chances c'est
vrai monsieur le député
en Allemagne en Italie
même aux États-Unis m'entendez bien même
aux États-Unis je sais de quoi je parle
on pense que la Crimée doit retourner
à l'Ukraine
donc on peut s'en tenir au formalisme du
droit international sur des positions
comme je vous l'ai déjà dit où je prends
pas part
on peut reprendre mes propos
maintenant que la Crimée historiquement
appartient à la Russie depuis Catherine
II et que krokchef pour faire plaisir
dans l'histoire du Parti communiste etc
face
qu'elles deviennent
ukrainiennes oui donc nous sommes en
face vraiment de quelque chose qui est
difficile moi-même j'ai été dans le
domaine les populations sont russophiles
il n'y a aucune
aucune et souhaite la Russie il a su il
n'y a aucune incertitude je tiens les
analyses que les services américains
eux-mêmes ont fait sur la sur les votes
sur les populations sur comment
l'Ukraine se coupe en deux à partir de
l'Est etc sur la fracture entre
civilisation entre les deux mondes que
je voulais et c'est un échec moi réunir
mais c'est un échec
je suis sûr que l'Europe unie vera le
jour c'est un échec parce que dites-vous
bien vous êtes américain l'Allemagne
a comme un port export comme premier
partenaire la Russie et au premier
partenaire en Chine de fait l'axe
continental s'est constitué vous êtes
une politique vous êtes derrière un
continent qui fait deux fois votre pipe
vous êtes obligé de casser l'axe
continental
mais merci monsieur le Président j'ai
encore deux questions dans le
prolongement la discussion sur cette
année 2014 parce que c'est quand même
une année absolument fondamentale
comment expliquer vous ce hasard
entre la prise de position de Marine Le
Pen en faveur de l'annexion de la Crimée
et quelques semaines plus tard
concomitamment le fait qu'il y ait un
emprunt important pour aider
financièrement ce parti politique à
travailler qui se réalise laissez-nous
quand même croire et je pense que des
millions de français
s'interrogent sur cette concordance de
temps qui est assez surprenante comment
est-ce que vous l'expliquez
ça prouve que Marine Le Pen connais son
histoire
et je vous ai déjà dit dans aucune
chancellerie sans aucune chancellerie
peut-être en public mais en privé
personne vous m'entendez personne
du côté occidental c'est pas la question
pense oui mais si non ce n'est pas parce
que parce que la géopolitique est là et
la réalité des équilibré là le
commissaire vous pose la question du
lien qu'il y a entre entre le soutien à
l'induction de la Crimée et le prêt
et le prêt et le prêt a été évidemment
je vous ai rappelé ça et vous voulez pas
malheureusement te dire tout le monde le
prêt était engagé bien avant en 2013
nous étions pas en face de la Crimée
d'annexion de la crinée et il n'y avait
pas encore place la place Maidan
on est sur un moment très important je
les mémoire que jette cette période
c'est que les
les manifestations
les remous qui se passent en Ukraine
commencent tout au long de l'année 2013
[Musique]
se poursuit au début de l'année 2014 et
moi je vais vous poser la question à
l'inverse pourquoi est-ce que au
printemps 2014 Marine Le Pen président
du Front national n'arrête pas les
négociations qui sont en cours pour
cette emprunt russe alors que la Russie
a envahi l'est de l'Ukraine annexe
illégalement contrairement aux droits
international la Crimée et que la France
dont vous ne cessez de vous réclamer des
intérêts condamne
cet échapper pourquoi est-ce que ça ne
s'est pas arrêté quel est votre
explication
si on soutient et on défend les intérêts
de son pays comme vous le dites et vous
ne cessez de vous en réclamer c'est pour
ça que j'utilise vos mots on arrête tout
voilà on arrête tout
je vais vous expliquer
je revends sur les dates je n'ai pas le
dossier devant moi donc je peux pas vous
dire exactement quand négociations ont
commencé mais bien avant donc bien un an
avant
2013 moi mon avis janvier février
2013 je crois que je retrouve la date où
nous nous avons été rejetés par pour le
prêt d'Abou Dhabi
maintenant je vais vous dire tout de
suite les choses
en 93 je rencontre catchu que le
président craignant déjà à ce moment-là
les conseillers américains sont là
pour préparer ce que brésinski avait
préparé et lui il a mis lui-même la main
à la patte entre Allbright et nulan qui
sont
ces collaborateurs
dès la chute du Mur deux choses étaient
fondamentales pour les États-Unis qu'on
mette pas la main la France
sur la défense polonaise car si la
France faisait ça
les États-Unis ne peuvent pas contrôler
l'Europe occidentale et l'Europe de
l'Est
et c'est pour cela qu'ils avaient lancé
l'opération sans même consultation de
leasing selon des méthodes un peu
spéciales mais c'est eux qui font les
lois donc tout leur est permis
j'obtiens effectivement
que en face un appel d'offre
et je constate d'ailleurs que les
autorités françaises n'ont peut-être pas
le droit de nous soutenir et
je continue vous m'interroger non vous
m'interrogez sur l'Ukraine je vous dis
que dès de la chute du Mur dès la chute
du Mur les Américains
essayent de couper
l'Ukraine en deux et et que on comprend
votre analyse géologique à partir de là
et qu'à partir et qu'à partir de là tout
le reste suit et être patriote c'est
constaté ça et être suffisamment
indépendant pour mener une politique de
la France indépendante selon les
intérêts de la France
et suivez ce que fait à l'époque les
différents chefs d'État au moins dans
les discours
ils souhaitent le lien avec la Russie
et ce lien a été cassé et rompu et
croyez-moi les Russes ne sont pas
intervenus en Crimée par plaisir il
voulait tout simplement pas il ne
voulait tout simplement pas qu'on mette
la main sur les bases militaires c'est
ça la réalité
du commissaire vous y reprend la parole
s'il vous plaît merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur chafoseur Je vous ai
posé une question simple pourquoi est-ce
qu'en 2014 quel est votre lecture
Marine Le Pen qui est président du Front
National et qui vous a missionné sur
cette emprunt russe qui n'est pas une
mince affaire pourquoi est-ce qu'en 2014
après le début de la guerre en Crimée et
à l'est de l'Ukraine l'annexion illégale
de la Crimée pourquoi est-ce que Marine
Le Pen est vous n'arrêtez pas vos
opérations autour de cette empreinte
c'est une question simple apportez-nous
la réponse qu'est-ce qui préside au fait
que dans le printemps 2014 j'imagine que
quand même un moment le lendemain du 20
février du début de l'opération russe de
2014 est un moment posé la question bon
cette affaire est quand même un peu
embêtante qu'est-ce qu'on fait on arrête
on continue enfin j'imagine que vous
avez quand même ce sens politique
élémentaire pour se poser cette question
vous poser cette question Marine Le Pen
et vous pourquoi est-ce que Marine Le
Pen et vous n'arrêtez pas vos
négociations avec la Russie sur cette
emprunt russe ça prouve tout simplement
que Marine Le Pen a une dimension de
chef d’état parce que vous prenez
Emmanuel Macron il continue il invite
président Poutine et tient son discours
en ambassadeurs en 2019
et il invite également les États-Unis il
y a d'une part il y a d'une part il y a
d'une part la dimension bon que vous
voulez en faire une affaire de droit en
disant que attention je vous le répète
c'est de volonté délibérée que cette
cassure s'est faite et que je la
comprends
mais ne faites pas intervenir du droit
lorsque le droit 2014 est vraiment un
coup d'état la place maïdan est vraiment
un coup d'état
et je sais de quoi je parle je suis vil
les événements donc je je vous dis
simplement les Américains pour des
questions vitales
que je comprends parfaitement ont voulu
éviter un acte continental qui les
marginalisé
et qui rendait l'Europe occidentale
également indépendante il était donc
absolument fondamental si on voulait
garder la suprématie de garde de casser
cet axe et toutes les raisons sont
bonnes ce qui n'a pas empêché le
président Macron de continuer à chercher
un équilibre entre les États-Unis et la
Russie et avec la Chine
et donc tout simplement Marine Le Pen
qui a une vue aussi historique des
choses et aussi une vie politique des
choses nous aurions pu le faire je vous
ai répondu indirectement je vous ai dit
si j'avais senti une pression politique
nous aurions trouvé une autre solution
lorsqu'on a essayé de la mettre en
faillite elle personnellement et qu'au
dernier moment et à 10 jours ou 15 jours
près ça se jouait on a trouvé une
solution
et je n'ai pas fait pour Marine Le Pen
en sortant durant pour l'argent vous
savez l'argent je sais très bien comment
on gagne c'est pas je suis pas un homme
et je suis pas un homme d'argent et je
suis pas un homme d'argent je l'ai fait
parce que je n'accepte pas qu'une
puissance étrangère intervienne dans la
politique intérieure de la France
est-ce que est-ce que on a répondu à
votre question Monsieur le Commissaire
votre micro merci
oui vous refusez qu'une puissance
étrangère interne dans la boutique
étrangère de la France en tout cas elle
est intervenue dans le parti pour lequel
vous avez été lu vous allez travailler
voilà je me permets cette remarque vous
en faites beaucoup donc laissez-nous
aussi en faire j'ai une dernière
dernière question on saute
trois années est-ce que vous êtes
intervenu dans
[Musique]
l'organisation de la rencontre qui a eu
lieu entre Vladimir Poutine et Marine Le
Pen un an un mois pardon avant le
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle de 2017
ma réponse est très claire non
non
on trouvera pas d'ailleurs j'y suis pas
et d'ailleurs je la prends
peut-être anecdotique mais pour vous
tout vous dire je la prends par mes amis
russes
je n'ai même pas été informé ce qui
prouve que la présidente est libre voilà
c'est terminé très bien
je crois que vous aviez encore au moins
une question je reprendrai un peu la
parole ensuite
oui merci aussi c'est une déformation
je voudrais revenir si vous voulez sur
les propos que vous avez eu parce que je
trouve qu'il est très difficile quand on
parle de ce des sujets d'ingérence
depuis 5 mois d'avoir des réponses
factuelles dans un sens ou dans l'autre
on entend des rumeurs des rapprochements
et dès qu'il s'agit que c'est
rapprochements deviennent concrets avec
des faits précis des moments précis des
informations précises tout attendant ça
à s'évanouir ou en tout cas à ne jamais
apparaître dans la précision
nécessaire donc vous dites à un moment
vous avez dit déclarations de France 2
je l'ai le verbatim donc je peux pas
faire des de fautes que Monsieur Poutine
vous l'avait redit aujourd'hui d'une
manière ou d'une autre est d'accord avec
le fait que la le premier prêt soit
accordé est-ce que oui ou non ce que
vous dites relève de votre intime
conviction ou est-ce que oui ou non vous
avez des éléments qui vous permettent de
dire qu'il a
et je question parallèle de la même
façon vous dites qu'il y a une puissance
étrangère
bloqué à notre prêt est-ce que oui ou
non parce que le président a juste titre
a dit c'était des allégations donc pour
moi ça parle comme des allégations parce
qu'il y a pas de fait donc les
allégations sur le fait que les
États-Unis auraient bloqué après moi de
l'autre côté pour le moment le fait que
Vladimir Poutine est autorisé un prêt
m'apparaît dans les informations que je
disposerai à ce que vous avez donné
aujourd'hui par un paralysme de forme
aussi des allégations est-ce que vous
avez des faits précis
votre collègue a trouvé que je peux
répondre de manière précise alors il
faudra que je vous réponde aussi précise
c'est une pure il va de soi dans le
fonctionnement russe que si non je vous
réponds je vous dis clairement il n'y a
pas de lien entre
il n'y a pas de lien que le président
Poutine aurait donné insatisfait de
chips sur ce prêt je dis simplement
quelque chose qui est évident il est
informé sans doute je ne peux pas le
savoir je suis pas dans les bons et sans
doute qui ne s'y oppose pas on me pose
la question ben évidemment et on me pose
la question pourquoi l'aurait-il fait
parce que il suit ça ne me paraît pas
choquant mais pour vous répondre
clairement
c'est une induction c'est une pure
évaluation de ma personne oui oui
absolument vous faites bien de le
souligner
non
allez-y
merci monsieur le Président oui moi
personnel quand je ne sais pas je ne dis
pas donc je ne comprends pas mais c'est
ça dépasse cette audition quand de la
même façon dans l'interview vous donnez
à France 2 de complément d'enquête
service public comme à juste titre
souligner notre collègue aussi dance
school on parle de SMS qu'on fuitait
grâce à des accords russes du réseau
Anonymous et on nous dit que
c'est ces oligarques russes exprime une
satisfaction envers la position du Front
national sur le référendum au Crimée
de la même façon le journaliste vous
pose des questions
là-dessus d'ailleurs il dit
on fait remarquer que ce sont vos
opinions
vous dites après avec Marine Le Pen a le
sens de l'histoire donc est-ce que oui
ou non un moment dans la négociation de
ce prêt et dans sa valise il y a la
négociation 2013 comme la souligné notre
collègue après il y a sa réalisation en
2014 que repose la question puisque
visiblement c'est très compliqué de le
savoir ce que oui ou non à un moment
quelconque de ce de la négociation
l'attribution de ce prêt la position des
dirigeants du Front national sur la
Crimée sur les événements de Crimée sur
l'annexion illégale
au niveau du droit du droit
international de la Crimée a été un
sujet de négociation et d'accord de ce
prêt ou non
j'ai été très clair là-dessus je n'ai
pas suivi l'affaire Crimée je n'ai rien
la personne qui a suivi cette affaire ce
n'est pas moi je ne suis pas allé en
Crimée les SMS sont doués avec des
personnes que je ne connais pas
en plus ce qui sont des acquaires ma
position soit la Crimée on s'en tient la
commission des affaires étrangères de ma
position personnelle donc je vous
réponds très clairement je j'ignore tout
de ça de des personnes et des échanges
des sms je ne traite pas l'affaire de
Crimée et et il n'y a pas eu il n'y a
pas eu de pression maintenant qui
consisterait à dire que parce que il y a
eu près il y aurait eu par ailleurs
comme on puisse dire parce qu'il y a eu
près il y aurait eu pression sur la
Crimée par les plus hautes autorités de
l'État non
parce que s'il y avait eu moi-même
j'aurais dit c'est hors de question
qu'on poursuive cette affaire il n'y a
pas eu pression
sur l'affaire de la Crimée par contre je
suis très clair là-dessus je
n'interviens pas ni de près ni de loin
je refuse d'y aller j'y suis invité à
plusieurs reprises
je vais reprendre la parole alors
très bien
[Musique]
pardon avez-vous effectué des voyages en
Russie ou en Ukraine avec Monsieur
Mariani et le cas échéant est-ce qu'elle
était le but ou les buts de ces voyages
je n'ai pas effectué de voyage avec
Monsieur Mariani nous sommes une fois
trouvé dans l'avion ensemble par hasard
bon vous savez que j'allais beaucoup
souvent en Russie
donc
voilà j'ai jamais été avec Monsieur
Mariani
alors chez Mariani à ses relations en
Russie j'ai les miennes ces deux choses
complètement cloisonnées nous n'avons
rien mais absolument rien avoir l'un et
l'autre d'accord pourtant d'après
certaines informations en octobre 2015
vous avez partagé un dîner avec des
membres du Parlement russe et certains
politiques français comme Thierry
Mariani
non
il y avait une grande manifestation où
il y avait 500 600 personnes mais il y
avait la gauche du Parlement européen
il y avait il y avait énormément de
monde il y avait aussi la Marion
maréchal mais on était 50600 j'étais pas
au repas en plus moi personnellement je
n'aime pas les grands repas je préfère
avoir des repas personnels et les repas
personnels que j'ai eu croyez moi
monsieur Mariani n'y était pas
d'accord très bien par ailleurs
connaissez-vous Monsieur Charles d'Anjou
et Régis le sommier
de Régis le sommier je le connais parce
que parce que quelqu'un qui me paraît un
journaliste
un journaliste important bon qui fait un
bon travail
si vous parlez de Louis XX
non mais Charles d'Anjou non mais Louis
vin oui
encore une question
quel est l'objet de l'association
revolver que vous avez fondé qui est
membre et quelles sont ses activités
un Volga si je me rappelle ça doit être
2006 2007 il est normal que l'ancien
responsable de la coopération
internationale de la région Alsace et
des régions européennes on lui propose
d'être président de cette association
vous savez toutes les missions que j'ai
effectuées en Russie que j'accepte
d'être si président de cette association
elle s'est fait en dehors de moi j'en ai
pas pris l'initiative on m'a demandé de
prendre la présidence et j'étais honoré
de l'apprendre parce que j'avais pas mal
d'amis centrices j'ai quand même été
collaborateur oui de Marcel rue de Love
son attaché parlementaire pendant toute
la période
certains diraient même sont son fils
certains dirontaient trahis
je connais Marcel rue deloff et je sais
tout ce qu'il m'a dit sur ce qu'il pense
de la politique française y compris le
centrisme alsacien qui n'est pas tout à
fait le centrisme parisien bon mais
peut-être que vous voyez ce que je veux
dire mais pour revenir donc c'était
complètement bon on demande j'accepte
nous avons fait du très bon
les plus beaux spectacles auxquels j'ai
assisté c'est en étant Président je sors
pas beaucoup mais mais c'est en étant
président de cette association
quels étaient les activités de cette
association de renforcer les rien entre
l'Alsace et la Russie nous avions signé
une convention et évidemment
il y a rien de
rien de choquant
ok oui il faut consulter les statuts
comme dit j'étais président alors que
j'étais l'association était déjà
constituée
merci monsieur le Président je voulais
juste faire un petit commentaire avant
que poser mes questions parce que vous
êtes manifestement un adepte du name
droping monsieur chaboser je ne sais pas
comment on dit name droping en russe
mais en disant vous citez abondamment
des personnalités souvent décédées
d'ailleurs dont nous souhaiterions que
la mémoire soit laissée en paix et vous
avez notamment un moment donné dit que
vous accompagnez autrefois Bernard Stasi
à l'Élysée entre 86 et 88 et dans la
foulée oui mais vous avez dit cela et
vous avez c'est j'avais bien entendu
mais c'est vous qui vous êtes trompé de
10 ans passivement comme vous avez cité
Jean Cerisé je souhaitais là aussi
c'était du temps du président Giscard
d'Estaing absolument et donc ça ne
collait pas avec les dates que vous
aviez donné et effectivement monsieur
cerisier là aussi épais à son âme n'est
pas là pour vous contredire
c'est ainsi que les choses sont
organisées ici dans une commission
d'enquête parlementaire vous avez dit
aussi et vous l'aviez dit dans le sujet
complément d'enquête de de France
Télévisions que l'intérêt des Russes du
pouvoir russe pour le Front National et
Madame Le Pen et était qu'elle pouvait
être considérée comme effectivement une
alliée le parti pouvait être considéré
comme faisant partie d'allier
occidentaux proche des idées et de la
vision géopolitique de de la Russie et
donc compatible avec l'envie d'avoir des
alliés complaisants à à l'intérieur de
de l'Union européenne vous l'avez dit et
vous nous l'avez redit en quelque sorte
ici très clairement vous avez aussi dit
que s'il y avait eu des pressions
politiques à un moment ou un autre sur
Madame Le Pen ou sur le front national
vous vous n'auriez vous auriez protesté
vous n'auriez pas toléré cela mais la
réalité et que il n'y a pas eu besoin de
pression politique puisque dès son
arrivée à la tête du Front national donc
dès 2011 Madame Le Pen a poursuivi et je
dirais même sérieusement amplifié la
politique de Jean-Marie Le Pen une
politique prorus et s'est rapproché
quand même de manière très prononcée
avec beaucoup d'obstination des cercles
du pouvoir poutinien de très nombreux
élus sont allés régulièrement elle-même
également en Russie rencontrer toute une
série d'interlocuteurs de plus en plus
proche du du pouvoir
poutinien ma question
deux questions ont été quels sont vos
relations avec Monsieur dougine
avez-vous déjà rencontré Monsieur
doughin et quel S sont vos relations
avec Aymeric choprad qui jouera un rôle
important comme conseiller international
de Madame Le Pen
je voudrais juste que vous préciser
quand même vos choses tout étape mène
une politique d'intérêt pendant que la
Russe menait cette politique Steve
Bannon qui est resté proche de service
américain
qui restait proche des services
américains mener une écoutez je sais de
quoi je parle la question n'est pas sur
Steve banane s'il vous plaît j'étais
aussi j'étais aussi avec lui quand il
était à Londres quand il était un
certain bon Steve Bannon faisait le lien
très efficace
de toutes les mouvements patriotiques ou
extrémistes dans tout l'Europe Steve
Bannon a été invité également au meeting
du
rassemblement national
oui et donc vous constaterez qu'il y
avait cet équilibre entre les États-Unis
et
donc
et je crois que une fois que je suis
parti il y a aussi de bonnes relations
avec les États-Unis ce qui a le rôle de
la présidente d'entretenir de bonnes
relations avec tout le monde
maintenant pour revenir à votre question
précise
rappelez-moi
monsieur dougine je ne le connais pas
il a été une fois chez moi
avec une autre personnalité parce qu'il
était là je l'ai reçu et
mais dans les années je sais pas quand
c'était ça devait être 2000 2009 2010
non avant Sarko était aux affaires donc
je l'ai reçu effectivement mais
rien de spécial je n'ai pas entretenu de
relation bonjour au revoir je l'ai
écouté et je partageais un certain
nombre de choses et puis c'est plus rien
passé je l'ai revu après à l'ambassade
parce qu'il y a eu une petite fête alors
enfin un petit repas etc mais ce n'est
eu aucune relation avec Monsieur dougine
suivi ce que je veux dire entre
rencontrer une personne et avoir des
relations suivies de travail et alors la
deuxième question donc là c'est très
clair non enfin non je vous dis la
vérité quoi
je l'ai rencontré une fois mais il n'y a
rien avec Aymeric choprade bon Aymeric
est un ami oui je j'ai apprécié j'ai
pris contact avec lui parce que il avait
écrit ce livre pour l'école de guerre
qui était un très bon livre
il voulait avoir des relations en Russie
je l'ai aidé
il a eu certaines relations que
moi je n'avais pas que moi je ne voulais
pas avoir je suis jamais allé dans
l'histoire des oligarques des trucs etc
ça m'intéresse pas ou bien on est dans
une politique d'État ou bien on n'est
pas dans une politique d'État si j'ai
des relations en Russie c'est parce que
je traitais un certain nombre de
dossiers pour le compte de société
française et c'est tout
pourtant je vous ai dit également que
pour moi il n'y a pas de problème pour
la Crimée mais
très bien voilà je passe la parole au
commissaire 6 ans merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur chafoseur j'aimerais
juste qu'on revienne sur la Crimée je
vais bien sûr de d'avoir compris ce que
vous avez dit vous avez dit que vous ne
faites pas occuper cette affaire de
Crimée que vous n'y êtes pas allé vous
avez dit ça
alors moi je suis étonné mais du coup je
vous pose la question parce que là j'ai
fait quelques recherches sur mon
téléphone en même temps je viens de
tomber sur un article de Rue 89
Strasbourg
je vais citer le paragraphe c'est un
article pour que chacun puisse le
trouver qui date du 13
du 13 mars 2022 et mon qui est assez
long qui concerne aussi d'autres
personnalités du rassemblement national
et il est écrit dans
dans cet article
attendez je suis remonté
non mais je parle mais je vais vous
poser la question directement parce que
voilà
j'ai sur la c'est ça quand on joue avec
le téléphone on perd le
on perd le film je présente ce que je
peux rendre la parole une minute vous
retournez
vous avez encore une question ou pas
merci c'est présence sujet complètement
différent monsieur chaofrozer aussi dans
le cas de cet entretien
à France 2 quel intérêt de la longueur
c'est le puis dire et de la
et d'être voilà enfin de relever d'une
conversation donc il y a une certaine
suite dans les idées vous interroge et
c'est déjà revenu dans le cadre de cette
commission dans le cadre de l'audition
de Philippe Olivier
d'un projet
Altin terre donc quand a été une
association
monsieur
mal aux fèves moi je sais pas voilà Malo
fiel que je ne parle pas non plus russe
les très peu je pense qu'on l'aura
compris depuis 5 mois de proximité avec
ce genre de personne
un projet de d'international
conservatrice enfin même on peut aller
au delà du conservatisme visiblement et
si vous voulez en vous écoutant parce
que moi je les ai quand même d'écouter
les auditions
avec un esprit ouvert j'ai noté quand
même dans vos propos un certain nombre
de signaux qui vont m'amener à poser
cette question vous avez parlé un
mouvement
désigner le pape du Saint Père de parler
de la famille Bourbon qui n'a aucune
réalité
reconnaîtrait en France plus de Louis XX
avait parlé un moment d'un ancien
commissaire européen qui lui-même était
membre de l'Opus Dei
si si tout à l'heure voter glionne
comment il s'appelle
vous en avez parlé vous avez parlé de
lui
vous êtes qualifié dans ce nombre
d'articles de différentes sources aussi
membres de loose di ma question c'est
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de poucedi
dans le projet politique est quand même
très éloigné de ma famille politique
est-ce que c'est vrai et est-ce que
finalement un certain nombre vous avez
vous-même tout à l'heure dit que vous
aviez une très grande liberté dans vos
actions et ma question finalement ce qui
m'a pas fait ce qui m'interroge au terme
de cette dans la fin de cette audition
est-ce que vous avez mené dans le cadre
de cette très grande liberté qui vous
avait été accordée un certain nombre de
projets qui sont vous avez le droit
d'ailleurs de les porter de les défendre
mais qui sont en fait très éloignés
d'ailleurs vous n'en est pas membres de
la ligne politique
on peut dire un peu plus laïque et
nationaliste du Front national
je crois vous savez dans ma vie
pourrait en parler à la Présidente j'ai
toujours été loyal
loyal à mes convictions
effectivement
je suis de formation philosophe et
théologien philosophe d'abord
après je réussis
à 19 ans je suis élève professeur en
philosophie donc je vais abandonner la
théologie puisqu'on ne paye comme élève
professeur
mais je continue la théologie quand même
donc c'est vrai que je suis quelqu'un
qui est et Rocco boutique lionne était
un ami parce qu'il était philosophe je
suis thomiste de formation
et je tout ça ça concerne mes
convictions intimes comme ça mes
convictions religieuses elles n'ont
jamais interféré
ce Tanguy jamais avec le service de mon
pays
jamais
plutôt plus s'il y avait une
contradiction
je ne refuserai la mission
donc voulez-vous que je vous dise
d'autres
je n'ai pas poursuivi un dessin propre
et croyez-moi mes relations quand même
je rentrais dans le bureau de Marine Le
Pen quand je voulais et elle pouvait
prendre son téléphone évidemment quand
elle voulait si quelque chose l'avait
choqué elle m'aurait appelé je crois pas
qu'elle ait eu besoin de le faire
pendant les 5 ans de mon mandat
me faites pas ce procès là
très bien
la réponse à votre question
le micro s'il vous plaît
non monsieur prise ma question n'est pas
une attaque personnelle laissez
d'établir des faits une fois de plus
parce que j'essaie de faire depuis 5
mois ma question n'est pas de savoir si
vous avez été déloyale les années
absolument pas mentionné ce mot je n'ai
pas je ne suis pas le juge des reins et
des cœurs je ne suis pas le juge des
opinions je n'ai jamais fait pendant 5
mois ma question est si ce réseau ce
projet
altère donc d'union
cette personne qui se réclame une
idéologie de reconquête chrétienne de
l'Europe est-ce que oui ou non vous en
avez eu connaissance est-ce que oui ou
non vous y avez participé factuellement
je vous demande si oui non vous êtes
membre de le poser c'est pas un crime
c'est pas illégal en France c'est une
question vous pouvez dire oui vous
pouvez dire non je vous pose cette
question parce que je vous avais
mentionné de choses que personne nous a
obligé à mentionner personne vous a
obligé à qualifier le prétendant de la
branche légitimiste de Louis vin
personne vous a oublié à parler du Saint
Père et non du pape personne ne vous a
obligé à citer certains nombre de
personnes que vous avez cité
volontairement monsieur Chat donc ce
n'est pas moi qui porte des accusations
qui sortent de ma tête ce sont des
réflexions en tant que commissaire et
quand je n'ai pas l'honneur de demander
à enfin de déporter pour que mon
collègue puisse briser cette commission
j'essaie d'établir des faits donc toutes
les questions que je vous ai posées
relèvent pas d'accusation ne relève pas
d'inquisition
c'est ce sont des faits non ce sont des
faits qui rien ne relève de la loi c'est
la relève de comprendre si oui ou non
vous avez vous-même réclamé le fait que
vous n'étiez pas adhérent au Front
national vous avez vous-même réclamé une
grande liberté et reconnue que cette
grande liberté vous été accordée ma
question n'est pas de savoir si vous
avez été déloyale c'est est-ce que dans
le cas de cette liberté vous avez mené
des projets qui n'étaient pas liés à la
ligne politique historique celle que
Marine Le Pen a gagné contre
monogoliniche en 2010 ce n'est pas faire
de déloyauté chacun le droit de mener
une ligne minoritaire c'est lui savoir
si oui ou non vous avez exercé une ligne
qui n'est pas celle du historique du
Front national tel que Marine Le Pen a
voulu ce n'est pas une accusation c'est
une question
concernant monsieur Malo et
je n'ai pas eu de relation avec Monsieur
manof
d'ailleurs de manière floutée de manière
scandaleuse dans mes propos au Parlement
que j'ai avec Aymeric où je lui dis bon
comme quoi ils ont ils ont tous les
droits
vous connaissez l'émission et on sort
des propos en commission des affaires
étrangères où je me tourne vers un
collègue pour lui dire attention et
on enregistre
ces propos personnels et on s'en sert
médiatiquement
médiatiquement tous les moyens sont bons
tous les moyens sont légaux quand on est
le maître les questions maintenant donc
j'ai répondu pour mal au fait
maintenant
mes convictions oui je suis membre de
l'opusé depuis 1980
oui je crois à une Europe chrétienne
absolument oui je crois qu'il était
nécessaire de faire un approchement
entre
d'une part l'Europe aux orthodoxe et
l'Europe enfin l'Europe catholique et le
reporte
orthodoxe pourquoi parce que nous sommes
en phase d'une civilisation
issue de l'individualisme du
protestantisme qui conduit au
subjectivisme relativisme et qui est
fondé sur l'argent qui structure la
société sur l'argent
et que d'autre part nous avons le
système communiste qui est un même
système aussi matérialiste et que je
souhaite je souhaite m'inscrire dans
cette grande tradition qui est celle de
la France
fille est né de l'église et et qui dont
général de Gaulle disait que l'histoire
commence avec le baptême de Clovis
vous me posez une conviction des
convictions au-delà je vous réponds par
conviction que il est certain que vu ma
liberté
j'ai je poursuis depuis
que je suis engagé depuis donc
1980 même dans la coopération dans tout
ce que j'ai pu faire je poursuis ce
dessin qui fait partie de mes valeurs ne
me reprochez pas mes valeurs il y en a
d'autres qui ont des valeurs
franc-maçonnes il y en a d'autres qui
ont des valeurs subjectivistes
relativistes etc moi ce sont mes valeurs
voilà ok mais sur sur Altin chose
Président vous devrez le Parlement devra
me payer une chambre d'hôtel parce que
je crains que je vais être obligé de de
garder de pas pouvoir rentrer chez moi
je sais pas si c'est prévu dans le
fonctionnement de cette commission je
vais moi-même louper mon avion et je
pense pas que le Parlement comme
rembourser parce que c'est le
parlementaire c'est pas la même chose
donc par contre si on revient sur le
sujet vous n'avez pas répondu à une des
questions il y en avait au moins trois
j'en ai retenu une deuxième c'était
votre appartenance ou votre
participation au mouvement Al interne
très clair non je peux pas à la fois
faire partie dire que et en même temps
donner ce qui est révélé à dire à Chopra
d'attention
cela plus l'objet d'une secte que que
voilà d'accord quel était votre
troisième question c'est un souvenir
et je vous en prie merci de me permettre
de la précéder une dernière fois je
prendrai plus la parole après évidemment
ma question était dans le cadre des
convictions que vous avez affirmés mais
vous demandez pas à une profession de
foi de si oui ou non vous reconnaissez
que cette ligne cette conviction ce
combat tout ce que vous voulez qui est
légitime pour toutes citoyen français ce
qu'il veut dans le cadre du respect de
la loi de la Constitution
est-ce que ce qui est le cas les
opinions que vous avez donné si je les
partage pas du tout n'est pas la ligne
de Marine Le Pen telle qu'elle l'a
présenté au Front national qu'elle a
gagné en 2010 est-ce que wino vous
reconnaissez que c'est votre combat et
pas celui du Front national
absolument marine je t'ai jamais caché
mes convictions Marine Le Pen et elle
n'est jamais intervenue sur toutes mes
interventions en 5 ans me disant l'âge
Jean-Luc tu peux pas ou tu fais pas ça
jamais parce que je tenais compte de ce
qu'elle pense
c'est tout donc il y a d'une part mais
convictions il y a d'autres parts quand
je parle et quand je préparais la liste
des votes par exemple
bon
jamais ce que c'est ce que vous me
demandez lorsque j'étais le rapporteur
pour la commission des affaires
étrangères lorsque lui a lui est parti
jamais donc je distinguais bien ce qui
était de l'ordre où je laissais liberté
de vote aux responsables vous verrez
vous prenez les listes de votre de
l'époque chacun votre selon ses
convictions je m'étais
donc c'est très clair et je n'ai jamais
caché mes convictions Marine Le Pen elle
les connaît parfaitement
elle m'a quand même fait confiance c'est
tout
très bien
ça sera très peu à voir avec la Russie
mais enfin bon c'est une question sans
problème interne
Président je ne plaisante pas moi je
veux bien passer la nuit ici mais mais
j'ai pas d'autre train et donc dans ces
conditions je veux bien j'ai déjà dit
aux responsables de de
fonctionnaires responsable que je veux
bien me déplacer mais j'enverrai mon
billet et je veux bien passer la nuit
mais je ne prendrai pas sur mes deniers
j'avoue que sur ce sujet je n'ai pas le
moyen de vous répondre instantanément
vous remarquerez aussi que si nous
arrivons une heure aussi tardive c'est
que vous êtes longuement exprimé par
moment et que nous avons été obligés de
vous couper donc je voudrais si
maintenant que vous avez posé votre
dernière question monsieur Tanguy passer
la parole à nouveau à monsieur sizensto
qui a retrouvé l'article cité
merci monsieur le Président oui
effectivement je prie la commission
d'avoir fait perdre quelques minutes je
m'étais embrouillé dans les articles
donc je suis retombé sur un article
monsieur chauffower de Rue 89 Strasbourg
en date du 2 novembre 2014 donc cet
article est intitulé Jean-Luc chaffozer
observateur des élections des
séparatistes Ukrainiens dimanche qu'on
parcours l'article et à la fin de cet
article je lis
et ça m'a troublé donc il est écrit par
le journaliste l'ancien candidat à la
mairie de Strasbourg c'est vous puisque
par ailleurs vous l'avez pas précisé
vous invitez candidat aussi aux
élections municipales à Strasbourg en
2014 donc Jean-Luc chafauzer est l'un
des personnages clés dans les connexions
du Front national avec la Russie et donc
là il est écrit il s'était déjà rendu en
Crimée lors du référendum entre
guillemets de mars au cours duquel les
habitants avaient le choix entre être
attachés à la Russie tout de suite ou
dans 5 ans donc du coup c'est en
contradiction avec ce que vous avez dit
donc j'aimerais juste que vous préciser
voilà vous avez nouveau l'exemple vous
avez toutes les conneries qu'on a
raconté sur me concernant je ne suis
jamais allé en Crimée c'est clair ce net
et précis
très bien vous avez encore une question
oui et du coup j'ai une j'ai une
dernière question
plus politique parce que vous avez
tout au long de la discussion que nous
avons et qui est une discussion
importante dans l'histoire des liens
entre entre le Front national
rassemblement national et la Russie de
Monsieur Poutine
vous en êtes beaucoup pris aux
États-Unis
Occident autant enfin bon et on retrouve
effectivement tout le vocabulaire
d'ailleurs que retrouve
autour voilà non je ne vous permet pas
je ne vous permets pas de le dire je
vous permets pas de dire ça et comme
gaulliste et comme alsacien Goli je ne
vous permet pas de dire ça et de
convoquer la figure du général de Gaulle
sur le sujet de la Russie ce que je
rappelle juste que lors de la crise des
missiles de Cuba général de Gaulle a été
le premier à soutenir président Kennedy
et que lorsque général de Gaulle était
président de la République notre
alliance c'était l'Alliance atlantique
soviétique mais
le général de Gaulle n'a jamais noué
d'alliance avec la Russie soviétique du
coup je veux revenir j'ai une question
quand même politique parce que en vous
écoutant on a le sentiment en fait qu'il
y a une équivalence
entre les États-Unis d'Amérique
qui est un état ils sont ce qu'ils sont
ils ont leur défauts on peut quand même
leur connaître que ce sont une
démocratie ce sont nos alliés ce sont
nos alliés dans le cadre de l'alliance
atlantique et tous les gouvernements
français ont fait continuer cette
alliance et de l'autre côté la Russie
dirigée par Monsieur Poutine depuis 1999
qui est un état
dans le système politique
n'est pas démocratique et qui a par
ailleurs par ailleurs eu des actions
quand nos intérêts notamment en Afrique
etc donc moi j'ai vraiment le sentiment
que vous mettez sur un pied d'égalité
les États-Unis d'Amérique et la Russie
de Monsieur Poutine et j'aimerais que
vous vous élaboriez
rapidement
entre entre vous savez les États-Unis
d’eisenhower ou de Roosevelt qui se qui
déjà le grand le grand danger du
Lipstate et comment une
l'état profond ça veut dire que c'est
une petite clique de fonctionnaire ou de
gens
qui sont liés par quelques sectes qui
essayent de prendre le pouvoir sur
l'état sur le bien commun à leur profit
donc je crois qu'il y a une dérive du
côté des États-Unis je crois sincèrement
quand je prends l'Irak la Libye la Syrie
les chaque fois les faux motifs
maintenant je vais être très clair avec
vous et mes amis américains le savent
pleurer encore 10 000 fois je connais
aussi la Chine si maintenant vous me
faites choisir entre la Chine et les
États-Unis je cours aux États-Unis donc
mon corps et aussi choisi d'ailleurs je
crois qu'on aurait pu éviter cette
guerre
qui pour moi était inéluctable vu le
rapport de force mais si on avait si les
Allemands n'avaient pas voulu jouer
d'une certaine manière avait voulu
rassurer
les États-Unis si les Allemands
n'avaient pas voulu à tout prix jouer
l'alliance avec la Chine pour revendre
aussi made in Germain et et dominé
économiquement si les Allemands avaient
rassuré sur le fait qu'ils font ce foie
là moi ce choix il est très clair
maintenant vous ne parlez ça n'a rien à
voir avec la commission ce choix est
très clair
entre le monde chinois communiste et
entre les États-Unis j'ai choisi les
États-Unis maintenant
si
je mets de manière équivalente la Russie
est quand même un pays
plutôt pratique mais ce n'est pas une
dictature
croyez moi j'ai été en Chine c'est pas
du tout j'ai pas du tout eu la même
impression
quand je suis en Russie ou quand je suis
en Chine c'est pas la même chose donc
je crois pas qu'il faut mettre en place
des valeurs il faut se poser la question
les alliances je reprends c'est quand
même le général de Gaulle qui fait le
traité de l'Élysée et se traiter à comme
objectif de créer une défense européenne
indépendante de l'OTAN bon ce sont les
Allemands qui sous pression dans
certains nombreux de députés du bundesta
que les Américains connaissent puisque
ce sont ils ont un passé disons il fait
pas je vais pas prendre ils ont un passé
ils sont tenus qui font remettre l'OTAN
de Gaulle a pris ça il le dit dans ses
mémoires comme une trahison donc
de Gaulle est quand même celui aussi qui
fait cette alliance avec la Chine
communiste et et fait ce voyage dans un
pays communiste la Russie la Russie
n'est plus communiste depuis la chute du
mur je la trouve on peut pas se lancer
maintenant dans une analyse géopolitique
globale parce qu'on sort complètement du
sujet même si c'est la question qui vous
a été posée mais je pense que je
souhaite interrompre en tout cas ce
débat qui est passionnant mais qui n'est
pas dans le cadre de cette commission
moi j'avais par ailleurs si vous avez
terminé commissaire encore une question
à vous poser qui revient plutôt sur
sur
sur votre votre parcours à la suite
d'une révélation de votre rôle
d'intermédiaire justement dans
l'obtention des prêts du FN le Parlement
européen est lancé en 2004 décembre 2014
une vérification de votre déclaration
d'intérêt quelle a été la conclusion de
cette initiative
tout était clair il n'y avait pas de
si jamais de problème avec le Parlement
très clair aussi pour les attacher
parlementaires aussi
ils ont vraiment travaillé ils ont fait
que travailler tout était clair j'étais
plus que transparent j'ai anticipé pour
parce qu'ils ont demandé des montants de
revenus possibles que je pourrais avoir
vu anticipé alors tout le monde a dit
gagner énorme j'ai donné le maximum pour
que on puisse pas me reprocher que
j'aurais dit donc vous anticipez vous
allez plutôt
dans ça a été tout ça ça a été vérifié
il y a rien eu à
rien à dire
très bien je vous remercie j'aurais
peut-être une j'ai fait plusieurs fois
d'ailleurs les choses évoluantes des
rectificatifs 4 ou 5 déclarations dès
que les choses évoluaient je faisais une
rectification et j'étais très clair en
plus Jean-Pierre traîné de très bonnes
relations avec depuis des années 80 avec
son secrétaire général et donc je lui
tenais au courant de tout de tout y
compris de mes missions merci
j'ai une dernière question et après je
sais peut-être une dernière fois la
parole au commissaire si vous vous posez
pouvoir vous libérer quel regard
portez-vous sur les activités de
l'association dialogue franco-rus les
avoue déjà rencontrés vous participez à
leur travaux
je n'ai jamais participé à leur travaux
j'ai pas eu cette honneur et et j'en
fais pas partie voilà
votre avis sur je crois qu'il existe
partout des associations franco-russes
il existe même des associations en
France
Qatar en France roche Orient voilà donc
je n'ai rien à dire je ne connais pas je
n'en fais pas partie je ne suis pas
invité voilà très bien y a-t-il une
dernière question monsieur les
commissaires Manola rapporteur une
dernière question qu'on puisse conclure
coupez votre micro s'il vous plaît
passons par ailleurs oui
justement en passant par ailleurs je
voulais juste rappeler vous avez
tenter des analyses
géopolitiques et comparé des régimes en
faisant des distinctions
entre démocratie régime autoritaire
dictature etc donc vous laissons
l'entière paternité je rappelle quand
même que la Russie est un état où et
c'était très précisément le 7 octobre
2006 une journaliste politique Anna
poliskopfler a été assassiné et où il y
a des
faits particulièrement odieux comme des
assassinats d'opposants au présent
Poutine à quelques centaines de mètres
du Kremlin qui qui se sont déroulées des
empoisonnements sur le territoire même
de l'Union européenne attribué au
service russe voilà tout cela doit quand
même être rappelé c'est ça la réalité du
régime de
Poutine je voulais juste être sûr
d'avoir bien compris parce que vous avez
vous-même fait une allusion tout à
l'heure j'avais pas l'intention
d'aborder ce sujet mais vous avez fait
allusion aux assistants parlementaires
en disant que tout était clair et
transparent donc vos assistants
parlementaires n'ont pas du tout été
pris dans la tourmente judiciaire qui
s'est emparée de nombreuses assistants
parlementaires à crédités que le Front
national
utilisé comme force de travail et qui
était pourtant des Asté parlementaires
accrédité censément travailler
uniquement à Bruxelles pour les députés
européens durant national donc vous avez
été de ce point de vue là extrêmement
clair et extrêmement tranchée ça n'est
pas du tout
votre cas et donc vous êtes sans
parlementaire et vous n'avez pas été du
tout inquiété par la par la justice
française dans le cadre de la grosse
affaire qui vaut quand même voilà une
saga judiciaire assez sérieuse à Madame
Le Pen et il y a d'autres députés
européens mais est-ce que vous aviez
du temps où vous étiez membre du
Parlement européen est-ce que vous aviez
eu vent
de cette organisation à ces systémiques
visant à faire en sorte que voilà vous
me posez cette question alors que les
médias ont fait état d'un certain nombre
d'échanges qui sont liés c'est quand
même c'est quand même extraordinaire
vous vous avez une perquisition
vous avez des pièces judiciaires
qui sont en possession des médias
ou entre autres dans un miel je m'oppose
à cette
je m'oppose à cette
bon c'est public bon est-ce que c'est
normal la question moi je vous retrouve
je me pose à
bon
je vois ça n'a rien à voir d'abord
ça n'a rien à voir avec eux absolument
mais moi je vous pose la question voyez
le pouvoir de puissance étrangère nous
sommes dans une démocratie
nous sommes dans une démocratie des
pièces judiciaires
sont en possession
des médias vous trouvez ça normal vous
comme parlementaire vous trouvez ça
normal vous trouvez ça normal que
lorsqu'une affaire n'est pas n'est pas
et entre autres comment pouvez-vous
accepter ça comment vous pouvez vous
accepter ça et et on me sort dans
l'émission me sort dans l'émission
ce mail que j'adresse personnellement à
valleyran
[Musique]
ce qu'ils ont regardé tous mes tous mes
mails pendant 5 ans 6 ans sont même
retourné jusqu'en 1990 en 1980
donc
je trouve ça très grave je trouve ça
très grave je suis je suis choqué
je n'aurais pas à m'exprimer sur cette
chose-là si ça avait pas été rendu
public ça regardez tout au plus la
police judiciaire mais ça ne regardait
pas la France
je trouve très grave que des affaires
confidentielles sortent pour fragiliser
en l'occurrence on cherche à fragiliser
Marine Le Pen bon moi me fragilise pas
je monte justement je suis pas d'accord
mais c'est pas normal laissez-moi le
dire que cela se retrouve en public pour
pour la fragiliser
elle ça c'est pas normal en démocratie
notre micro pardon le nom j'ai rien à
ajouter à cela ça n'est pas vous qui
posez des questions ici nous sommes dans
le cadre d'une commission d'enquête
parlementaire vous aviez vous-même fait
une allusion assez évidente en parlant
de transparence et de choses menées de
manière correcte et transparente et
claire aux assistants parlementaires et
donc à vos assistants parlementaires
mais le sujet éclos pour ce qui me
concerne très bien s'il n'y a pas
d'autres questions je vous propose que
nous levions cette séance Monsieur le
Commissaire
très bien la séance et donc lever